This episode is brought to you by Lloyds, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements, aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? A great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyds）赞助播出，该银行已支持英国的雄心壮志超过250年。说起来，历史上每一个王朝归根结底都离不开两个重要元素：抱负与行动。英国历史上一个经典的例子就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。是的，这是一个伟大的故事，不是吗，汤姆？我认为这对任何人来说都是一堂关于领导力的好课。所以，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人们，他们将理想主义与实用主义结合在了一起。
They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliance, of course, at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership. And, of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyd's to be ready when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters,
他们擅长结盟，擅长驾驭权力。当然，他们也擅长理财，这是政治领导力的关键部分。当然，我们都在享受他们智慧和远见的成果。当您需要做出下一个重大决定时，您可以信赖劳埃德银行，我们随时准备为您提供支持。因为从新企业到新家园，再到人生的新篇章，
backed by generations of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyds to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 26. crazed with the Belgian blood so lately shed the bestial Prussian seeks the ocean's bed In Neptune's realm the wretched coward lurks And on the world his wonted evil works
在几代人希望与抱负的支持下，汤姆，你可以看出为什么1400万人信任劳埃德银行，帮助他们实现梦想。基于劳埃德银行3月26日的内部客户数据。被最近流下的比利时人的鲜血所疯狂，野蛮的普鲁士人寻求海洋的深处，在海神的领域，卑劣的懦夫潜伏着，并在世界上行使他惯常的邪恶。
Like slinking cur He bites where none oppose Victorious over babes His valor grows One fateful day May such be never more A stately vessel left Columbia's shore Upon the wave in fearless grandeur road
像一只鬼鬼祟祟的狗，他在无人反抗的地方撕咬，在婴儿身上取得胜利，他的勇气增长。在那个决定性的日子里，愿这样的事永不再发生，一艘庄严的船只离开了哥伦比亚的海岸，在波涛上以无畏的雄姿航行。
Nor feared to bear its blameless, helpless load No human risk The watchful captain ran Protected by the common laws of man The laws of man What laws can curb or sway The Prussian wolf with manhood cast away his idle threat to hideous for belief
它不惧承载那无辜、无助的负荷。警惕的船长没有冒任何人的风险，受到人类共同法律的保护。人类的法律，什么法律能遏制或左右那抛弃了人性的普鲁士狼？他那令人难以置信的丑陋的虚假威胁，
with its foul truth plunged nations into grief. So that immortal work of poetry was the Crime of Crimes, Lucetania in 15 and it was first published by a young journalist called HP Lovecraft. And that is a name that will be familiar to any fans of horror stories today. the great pioneer of that genre. And he's celebrated as the inventor of Cthulhu, a terrifying and monstrous entity that lurks in hidden depths. And to quote Lovecraft of a form which only a diseased fancy could conceive.
以其肮脏的真相让各国陷入悲痛。那部不朽的诗作就是《罪中之罪》，卢西塔尼亚号在15年（1915年），它最初是由一位名叫H.P.洛夫克拉夫特的年轻记者发表的。这个名字对于今天任何恐怖故事的粉丝来说都很熟悉，他是该流派的伟大先驱。他被誉为克苏鲁的创造者，那是一个潜伏在隐藏深处的恐怖而怪异的实体。引用洛夫克拉夫特的话，那是一种只有病态的想象力才能构思出来的形态。
And that poem that I have just read also describes a source of awful dread that lurks in hidden depths. But it belongs to a very different kind of heart. horror story. And that horror story is the theme of today's episode, the third in our epic series on The Nightmare that was the world in 1915. And it is the story of how the liner RMS Lusitania came to be sunk by a German U-boat, or Dominic, as Lovecraft will put it, a Prussian wolf. Yes. So the Lusitania, everybody, was sailing from New York to Liverpool, and it was torpedoed off the coast of Ireland by a U-boat on the 7th of May, 1915, with the loss of more than a thousand lives.
而我刚才读的那首诗也描述了一种潜伏在隐藏深处的恐怖源头。但它属于一种非常不同的恐怖故事。而那个恐怖故事就是今天这一集的主题，这是我们关于1915年那个噩梦般世界的史诗系列中的第三集。这就是卢西塔尼亚号邮轮如何被德国U型潜艇击沉的故事，或者用多米尼克的话说，用洛夫克拉夫特的话说，是一只“普鲁士狼”。是的。所以，卢西塔尼亚号，各位，当时正从纽约驶往利物浦，于1915年5月7日在爱尔兰海岸被一艘U型潜艇鱼雷击中，造成一千多人丧生。
And as you know, Tom, this became one of the First World War's most emotive stories, but also one of its most controversial. So it became the subject of all kinds of legends and conspiracy theories. And actually, rather like the Cthulu mythos, this became the subject of a mythos itself. Did it? A mythos. A mythos, exactly. But like the story of the Titanic, this is a tremendous human drama. So it's a great story about individuals and what happens to individuals in conditions of extreme stress. But also, it's a fantastic window into the story of Germany's U-boat campaign and the strategic
正如你所知，汤姆，这成为了第一次世界大战中最令人动容的故事之一，也是最具争议的故事之一。它成为了各种传说和阴谋论的主题。实际上，就像克苏鲁神话一样，这本身也成为了一个神话体系。是吗？一个神话体系。没错，一个神话体系。但就像泰坦尼克号的故事一样，这是一场巨大的悲剧。所以这是一个关于个人以及在极端压力下个人会发生什么的好故事。但它也是了解德国U型潜艇战役和战略的一个绝佳窗口，
dilemmas that are facing friend of the show, Kaiser Wilhelm II, and his commanders. One other aspects of this story, though, this is a crucial moment in the story of how the United States ends up being drawn into the First World War. So, just to remind people, we are... Not yet 12 months into the Great War. And at this point, there is no suggestion that the United States will ever take part. So there are a small number of, I suppose you'd call them now Atlantisists, kind of pro-British Americans. But against them, there are millions of Americans of German descent or Scandinavian or indeed Irish descent who are dead against intervening.
以及节目之友德皇威廉二世及其指挥官们所面临的困境。不过，这个故事的另一个方面是，这是美国最终被卷入第一次世界大战的故事中的一个关键时刻。所以，提醒一下大家，我们……距离大战开始还不到12个月。在这一点上，没有任何迹象表明美国会参与其中。所以有一小部分人，我想你现在会称他们为“大西洋主义者”，即亲英的美国人。但与他们相对的，是数以百万计的德裔、斯堪的纳维亚裔，甚至是爱尔兰裔美国人，他们坚决反对干预。
And the US president at this point is a Democrat. He is Woodrow Wilson. And Woodrow Wilson has explicitly ruled out intervening in this European war, not least because Irish Americans are a massive part of the democratic governing coalition. And Wilson at this point, so we're talking about 1915, is already thinking that in the long run, maybe he can step in to sort of orchestrate a compromise piece. He's already beginning to fancy himself as a great sort of world statesman.
当时的美国总统是一位民主党人。他是伍德罗·威尔逊。伍德罗·威尔逊明确排除了干预这场欧洲战争的可能性，尤其是因为爱尔兰裔美国人是民主党执政联盟的重要组成部分。而威尔逊在这一点上，也就是我们谈论的1915年，已经在考虑从长远来看，也许他可以介入，以某种方式促成妥协和平。他已经开始自诩为一位伟大的世界政治家。
and there's the man who's going to put the world to rights. And this will be tremendous for him at home, of course, and all of this kind of thing. And, of course, we all know how that plays out in the long run. Yeah, because he loves birth of a nation, the film that he's part of the Ku Klux Klan, but he does also love posing as the champion of world peace. So a man of contradictions, one might say. Yes, exactly.
他是那个将要让世界重回正轨的人。当然，这对他在国内来说将是巨大的成就，诸如此类。当然，我们都知道这在长期来看是如何发展的。是的，因为他喜欢电影《一个国家的诞生》，他是三K党的一员，但他确实也喜欢装作世界和平的捍卫者。所以，人们可能会说，他是一个充满矛盾的人。是的，完全正确。
So now the Sink of the Lucitania does not bring the United States immediately into the war. It takes another couple of years for that to happen, but it's an absolutely crucial step along that road. So let's get into the actual story and let's start, rather like when we did our series about Titanic, we started with the ship. Let us start with the ship herself, the Lusitania. So the Lusitania, we are very much team White Star, aren't we, at the rest of its history. Oh, definitely, yeah. But the Lusitania belongs to their rivals, Cunard.
所以，卢西塔尼亚号的沉没并没有让美国立即参战。这还需要几年时间，但这是通往那条道路上绝对关键的一步。那么让我们进入实际的故事，让我们开始吧，就像我们做泰坦尼克号系列时一样，我们从船开始。让我们从这艘船本身开始，卢西塔尼亚号。所以卢西塔尼亚号，我们在历史的其他部分绝对是白星航运公司的团队，对吧？哦，当然，是的。但卢西塔尼亚号属于他们的竞争对手，卡纳德航运公司。
And it's a Cunard liner launched in 1906 as part of the competition for the Atlantic passenger trade that produced the Titanic. So for a brief period, the Lusitania was the world's biggest ocean liner. It had capacity for 2,200 passengers. It had six passenger decks. It was extremely luxurious. So it's a little bit like the Titanic, but just not as good, frankly. The Titanic goes above and beyond. I mean, the Titanic is more luxurious, isn't it?
它是一艘卡纳德邮轮，于1906年下水，是大西洋客运贸易竞争的一部分，这场竞争也催生了泰坦尼克号。所以，在很短的一段时间内，卢西塔尼亚号是世界上最大的远洋客轮。它有容纳2200名乘客的能力。它有六层客舱甲板。它极其豪华。所以它有点像泰坦尼克号，但坦率地说，没那么好。泰坦尼克号超越了它。我的意思是，泰坦尼克号更豪华，不是吗？
Because that's what White Star makes great play with. But to be fair, the Lusitania is faster, because that's the great selling point of Cunard. Yeah, that's right. So the Lusitania actually won the blue ribbon for the fastest Atlantic crossing. And up for the previous 10 years or so, German ships had been the masters of the seas. But the Lusitania beats them. It's faster. Do you think that's part of the motivation?
因为那是白星航运公司大做文章的地方。但公平地说，卢西塔尼亚号更快，因为那是卡纳德航运公司最大的卖点。是的，没错。所以卢西塔尼亚号实际上赢得了大西洋最快横渡的“蓝飘带奖”。在过去10年左右的时间里，德国船只一直是海洋的主宰。但卢西塔尼亚号击败了它们。它更快。你认为这是动机的一部分吗？
Revenge. Revenge. Because I wanted revenge on this fast ship. Winning back the blue ribbon. I don't think so. I don't think so. Now, as with a lot of other liners, the construction of the Lusitania, and this will become important later on when it's sunk, the construction had been subsidized by the British government. on condition that in the event of a war, the Lusitania could be converted into an armed merchant cruiser.
复仇。复仇。因为他们想要对这艘快船进行复仇。赢回蓝飘带奖。我不这么认为。我不这么认为。现在，和许多其他邮轮一样，卢西塔尼亚号的建造——这在后来它沉没时会变得很重要——是由英国政府补贴的，条件是如果发生战争，卢西塔尼亚号可以被改装成武装商船。
So there's actually space built in on the deck for naval guns, even though they're not actually installed. And when war breaks out in August 1914, the Lusitania is very briefly requisitioned by the Admiralty. But the issue with these massive Cunard liners is that they are so expensive to run. They're basically too big. and the cost of the coal alone is prohibitive. It's so high up. How on earth would you fire guns from it? I suppose you could aim down?
所以甲板上实际上预留了安装海军炮的空间，尽管它们实际上并没有安装。当1914年8月战争爆发时，卢西塔尼亚号被海军部短暂征用。但这些巨大的卡纳德邮轮的问题在于它们的运营成本太高了。它们基本上太大了。仅煤炭的成本就高得令人望而却步。它那么高。你到底怎么从上面开炮？我想你可以向下瞄准？
I don't know. I'm not really an expert on naval armaments. Anyway, can not get the ship back. The demand for ocean crossings obviously falls in the first months of the war. But, you know, people are still crossing the Atlantic. And in the winter of 1914, 15, Lusitania is still the fastest first-class liner that is, you know, going back and forth across the Atlantic waves.
我不知道。我真的不是海军武器方面的专家。总之，无法收回这艘船。战争头几个月，对大西洋横渡的需求显然下降了。但是，你知道，人们仍然在横渡大西洋。而在1914-1915年的冬天，卢西塔尼亚号仍然是往返于大西洋波涛之上的最快的一等邮轮。
So the Lusitania is going back and forth. But the world's attention is focused on a very different kind of boat. And this is one of the First World War's great military innovations. And this is, of course, the U-boat. So I was astonished to discover as not a great, you know, I've never really taken any interest in submarines until I was preparing this episode. That the first military submarine was developed in 1775 as part of the tax revolts in North America, which many of our American listeners will be celebrating this year.
所以卢西塔尼亚号在往返航行。但世界的注意力集中在一种非常不同的船只上。这是第一次世界大战中伟大的军事创新之一。这就是，当然，U型潜艇。所以我很惊讶地发现，作为一个——你知道，在准备这一集之前，我从未对潜艇产生过任何兴趣——第一艘军用潜艇是在1775年作为北美税务起义的一部分开发的，我们许多美国听众今年会庆祝这一点。
Alexander the Great is meant to have built a submarine and gone down into the sea. Yeah, that's right. Wasn't there a submarine, a Confederate submarine that shot her ship in the American Civil War? The first submarine to go into action, I think, was a Confederate ship. But was it then destroyed by its own, it destroyed itself? Yes, I think it kind of blew up a ship and then blew up itself. So you win some, you lose some. The Americans are very much pioneers of this kind of thing.
亚历山大大帝据说建造了一艘潜艇并潜入了海底。是的，没错。在美国内战中，不是有一艘潜艇，一艘南方联盟的潜艇击沉了她的船吗？我想第一艘投入行动的潜艇是一艘南方联盟的船。但它后来是被它自己摧毁的，它摧毁了自己？是的，我想它炸毁了一艘船，然后炸毁了自己。所以有得必有失。美国人在这种事情上确实是先驱。
But basically, throughout the 19th century, you know, it's seen as a bit of a white elephant, the submarine. But then in the 1900s, the major naval powers had started building these fleets of submarines that could fire torpedoes and lay mines. And they thought of them really as coastal defence things, that they would kind of lurk around your coast. Somebody sends a fleet and your submarine will shoot it down or whatever. Because Jules Verne, he has the Nautilus, which must make it kind of seem very fashionable. Cutting edge. Yes, exactly. And the biggest submarine force in 1914, when war broke out, I'm happy to say, belonged to the Royal Navy.
但基本上，在整个19世纪，你知道，潜艇被视为一种“白象”（昂贵而无用的东西）。但在1900年代，主要海军强国开始建造这些能够发射鱼雷和布设水雷的潜艇舰队。他们真的把它们看作是海岸防御工具，它们会潜伏在你的海岸附近。有人派出一支舰队，你的潜艇就会把它击沉之类的。因为儒勒·凡尔纳，他有“鹦鹉螺号”，这一定让它看起来很时髦。尖端技术。是的，完全正确。而在1914年战争爆发时，我很高兴地说，最大的潜艇力量属于皇家海军。
So we had 75 boats, the French had about 50. And the Germans who you always think of, oh, the Germans love a submarine with a year. Yes, a sea wolf. They had 28 submarines. And most of those, well, at least a lot of those, were not even seaworthy. So they're very much lagging behind.
所以我们有75艘潜艇，法国有大约50艘。而德国人，你总是想到，哦，德国人喜欢潜艇。是的，海狼。他们有28艘潜艇。而且其中大多数，或者说其中很多，甚至都不适航。所以他们确实落后了。
And the reason is that their naval chief, Grand Admiral Alfred von Turpitz. So he's the sort of dreadnought baron, I suppose. Yes. He has a tremendous forked beard, Very impressive beard. Very offset by his kind of resplendent baldness, isn't it? Yeah, he's an odd-looking bloke, frankly.
原因在于他们的海军首脑，大海军上将阿尔弗雷德·冯·提尔皮茨。所以他是那种“无畏舰男爵”，我想。是的。他有一把巨大的分叉胡子，非常令人印象深刻的胡子。被他那种光彩照人的秃头所抵消，不是吗？是的，坦率地说，他是个长相奇怪的家伙。
So Turpitz, he's much more interested in his dreadnoughts than submarines. But just before the war, he'd said, well, we'll have some submarines. And he started ordering these new diesel submarines. And apparently diesel submarines are safer and harder to detect, but for reasons that I don't fully understand. The things you learn while preparing a podcast. Exactly.
所以提尔皮茨，他对无畏舰的兴趣远大于对潜艇的兴趣。但在战争爆发前不久，他说，好吧，我们会拥有一些潜艇。他开始订购这些新型柴油潜艇。显然，柴油潜艇更安全，更难被探测到，但原因我不太明白。准备播客时学到的东西。完全正确。
These submarines, they can go at speed of about six. knots, which for those of you who don't speak not, that's about 20 miles an hour. And they can go a heck of a long way. They can go 7,000 miles. So, you know, they can range around the seas of the world. And what's it actually like to be on a submarine? Well, if you're a German submariner, you're better treated than almost any other member of the German armed forces. You get better rations than anyone. But the reason for that is that it's absolutely awful being on a submarine. So to give people a sense, if you're on a U-boat, a U-boat is about 70 meters long and seven meters wide. So it's really cramped. And inside this sort of narrow metal cylinder, there are about
这些潜艇，它们的速度大约是6节，对于那些不懂“节”的人来说，大约是每小时20英里。而且它们可以走很远的路。它们可以航行7000英里。所以，你知道，它们可以在世界各地的海洋中航行。在潜艇上到底是什么感觉？好吧，如果你是一名德国潜艇兵，你受到的待遇几乎比德国武装部队的任何其他成员都要好。你的口粮比任何人都好。但原因在于，在潜艇上绝对是糟糕透顶。为了让人们有个概念，如果你在U型潜艇上，U型潜艇大约70米长，7米宽。所以真的很拥挤。在这个狭窄的金属圆筒里，大约有
40 men and all their food and supplies for an entire month. And also at Christmas, a Christmas tree. Yeah, they have a Christmas tree and tons of sausages, I think. I mean, genuinely, lots of sausages. So the crew are very often, you're very often seasick. You're only allowed to wash once a week because they need to save water. And to quote Alexander Watson in his brilliant book, Ring of steel about the Germans and the central powers at war. It's really hot. It's very thick and foul, a choking atmosphere of machine oil, cooking and sweat. That would make you feel seasick, wouldn't it? Yeah, it's basically like someone has sort of shrunk a kitchen, a sort of industrial kitchen, and you're in it, but you've also under the sea. I think it's just terrible. And of
40个人，以及他们整整一个月的食物和补给。还有圣诞节时的一棵圣诞树。是的，他们有一棵圣诞树和成吨的香肠，我想。我的意思是，真的，很多香肠。所以船员们经常，你经常晕船。你每周只允许洗一次澡，因为他们需要节约用水。引用亚历山大·沃森在他那本关于德国和同盟国战争的精彩著作《钢铁之环》中的话。真的很热。空气非常浓稠且污浊，充满了机油、烹饪和汗水的窒息感。那会让你感到晕船，不是吗？是的，这基本上就像有人把一个厨房，一个工业厨房缩小了，你就在里面，但你还在海底。我觉得这太可怕了。而且
course, it's terrifying. I mean, everyone thinks that U-boat strike terror into other people, but to be on a U-boat is really frightening. Yeah. You might get attacked by a giant, squid or something. At any moment, you might hit a mine, you might get tangled up in a net, you might be a shell or something, you might bump into a ship. And as one ship, U-boat commander, said at any minute, we could be thrown 100 meters up in the air or 100 meters under the water. So basically, you're in terror of your life the whole time.
当然，这很恐怖。我的意思是，每个人都认为U型潜艇给别人带来了恐惧，但在U型潜艇上真的很吓人。是的。你可能会被一只大王乌贼之类的东西攻击。随时你都可能撞上水雷，你可能会被网缠住，你可能会被炮击之类的，你可能会撞上一艘船。正如一位U型潜艇指挥官所说，随时我们都可能被抛向空中100米，或者被抛入水下100米。所以基本上，你一直处于对生命的恐惧之中。
And you're away for months at a time? Yes, exactly. You're away for a long time. You have months and months of waiting to run into a craken or hit a mine or something. Yeah, it's terrifying. Horrible. And the first U-Boats were sent out just two days into the war from Heligoland into the North Sea.
而且你一次要离开几个月？是的，完全正确。你要离开很长时间。你有几个月又几个月的时间在等待遇到海怪或撞上水雷之类的东西。是的，这很恐怖。太可怕了。第一批U型潜艇在战争爆发仅两天后就从黑尔戈兰岛被派往北海。
And their target wasn't really the Royal Navy so much as Britain's merchant shipping. So basically what the Germans thought was, as we've said so many times in this series, they're conscious of themselves as underdogs. And the way that they think they can bring Britain to its knees is to target its trade with the outside world. So Britain in 1914 imported almost two-thirds of all its food,
他们的目标与其说是皇家海军，不如说是英国的商船。所以基本上德国人的想法是，正如我们在本系列中多次提到的，他们意识到自己是弱势群体。他们认为可以使英国屈服的方法是针对其与外部世界的贸易。所以1914年的英国进口了其所有食物的近三分之二，
including all of its sugar. Obviously, Britain doesn't produce its own sugar. It imported half of its meat and almost half of its wheat. A lot from Denmark, I think. Meat from Denmark, surely. A lot of bacon, bacon and ham from Denmark. Well, the Danes, they have great bacon, don't they? Yeah, amazing.
包括所有的糖。显然，英国不生产自己的糖。它进口了一半的肉类和近一半的小麦。我想很多来自丹麦。肉类来自丹麦，肯定。很多来自丹麦的培根、火腿。嗯，丹麦人，他们有很棒的培根，不是吗？是的，太棒了。
I think they have tremendous bacon. And wheat from Canada, I suppose, from the prairies and stuff. Beef from Argentina. All these kinds of things. So the German strategy is essentially to starve Britain into submission. rather as Britain had, that was the strategy that Britain had applied in the Napoleonic Wars against France and I is applying against Germany now. It's the default British strategy and the Germans are trying to pay them back in their own coin.
我想他们有很棒的培根。还有来自加拿大，我想，来自大草原之类的。来自阿根廷的牛肉。所有这些东西。所以德国的战略本质上是让英国挨饿以求屈服。就像英国在拿破仑战争中对法国采取的战略，以及现在对德国采取的战略一样。这是默认的英国战略，而德国人正试图以牙还牙。
Exactly. And actually just before the war, Arthur Conan Doyle had written a short story with the tremendous title, Danger. That is a great title. And basically this short story predicted that with a very small force of U-boats, Germany or some adversary could destroy Britain's main. merchant shipping and cause mass hunger and bring Britain cap in hand to the negotiating table. Oh, like in 1976. Like in 1970s. Exactly.
完全正确。实际上在战争爆发前不久，阿瑟·柯南·道尔写了一篇短篇小说，标题非常棒，叫《危险》。那是一个很棒的标题。基本上这篇短篇小说预测，只要用一小支U型潜艇部队，德国或某个对手就可以摧毁英国的主要商船，造成大规模饥荒，并迫使英国带着请求来到谈判桌前。哦，就像1976年那样。就像1970年代那样。完全正确。
You know, this was well known in Germany. The German sort of high command and the German public absolutely believe that this is the way to beat Britain. And so in the last months of 1914, Grad Ambril Terpitz and the chief of the German Admiralty staff, who is a guy called Hugo von Paul, they are arguing with other commanders and they are saying, right, the way to win this war is this aggressive. kind of gloves-off campaign against British merchant shipping. And does that include liners?
你知道，这在德国是众所周知的。德国的高层指挥部和德国公众绝对相信这是击败英国的方法。所以在1914年的最后几个月，大海军上将提尔皮茨和德国海军参谋长，一个叫雨果·冯·波尔的人，他们正在与其他指挥官争论，他们说，对，赢得这场战争的方法就是这种激进的、不择手段的针对英国商船的战役。这包括邮轮吗？
Well, this is the complexity. Because, of course, liners are transporting a lot of cargo, so they are absolutely part of that. But at this point, the U-boats, like other ships, are still obeying what are called at the time prize rules or cruiser rules. This is the sort of established convention of how you fight a war at sea. People remember from our Nelson series that there are always these sort of almost unwritten codes
嗯，这就是复杂之处。因为，当然，邮轮正在运输大量货物，所以它们绝对是其中的一部分。但在这一点上，U型潜艇，像其他船只一样，仍然遵守当时所谓的“奖金规则”或“巡洋舰规则”。这是海上战争如何进行的既定惯例。人们从我们的纳尔逊系列中记得，总是有这些几乎不成文的准则
that govern naval warfare. And this is as true in 1914 and 1950 as it was in the 1790s. So in the 1910s, the understanding is that basically if you see a merchant ship and you're a U-boat, you surface, you come to the surface, and you stop the ship and you demand to search it for contraband. You know, are you carrying war supplies and whatnot? But this is quite fiddly, I guess.
来管理海军战争。这在1914年和1915年和在1790年代一样真实。所以，在1910年代，人们的理解是，基本上如果你看到一艘商船，而你是一艘U型潜艇，你浮出水面，你来到水面，你拦住这艘船，你要求搜查它是否有违禁品。你知道，你是否携带战争物资之类的？但这相当麻烦，我想。
It's very fiddly. and you put the crew and any passengers, you make them get into, you either capture them, which obviously you can't do on a U-boat because you can't put more people on your U-boat, you make them get in the lifeboats, and then you blow up their ship.
这非常麻烦。而且你让船员和任何乘客，你让他们进入，你要么俘虏他们，这显然你在U型潜艇上做不到，因为你不能在你的U型潜艇上放更多的人，你让他们进入救生艇，然后你炸毁他们的船。
Of which there are now enough, thanks to the Titanic disaster. Exactly. There should be enough. You make it again in the lifeboats, then you sink their ship, or you capture it in some way. You don't just sink their ship without warning.
多亏了泰坦尼克号灾难，现在救生艇足够了。完全正确。应该足够了。你让他们进入救生艇，然后你击沉他们的船，或者以某种方式俘虏它。你不会只是在没有警告的情况下击沉他们的船。
The issue is, as you said, it's very fiddly and very difficult, and B, the British start disguising their warships as merchant ships to lure the Germans in. So it's a little bit like the bit with the Acheron in Master and Command of the film, if people have seen that, where Captain Jack Aubrey disguises his ship as a crippled whaler to lure the French in. You see, if that was the German policy, that would be cheating because it's us. It's cunning. It's cunning and clever. The other thing, of course, as you really mentioned, by the end of 1914,
问题是，正如你所说，这非常麻烦且非常困难，而且B，英国人开始将他们的军舰伪装成商船来引诱德国人。所以这有点像电影《怒海争锋》中关于“阿刻戎号”的那一段，如果人们看过的话，杰克·奥布里船长将他的船伪装成一艘残破的捕鲸船来引诱法国人。你看，如果那是德国的政策，那将是作弊，因为那是我们。这很狡猾。这很狡猾且聪明。当然，另一件事，正如你提到的，到1914年底，
the British have set up a naval blockade of Germany, basically closing the North Sea, because they're hoping to starve the Germans into submission. And faced with this, Grand Admiral Turpitz and the chief of staff, Hugo von Paul, say to the Kaiser and his Chancellor, Betman Holveg, could we please ditch these antiquated cruiser rules, as they're called, and can we embrace what's called unrestricted submarine warfare? In other words, the gloves are off. We're just going to attack your merchant ships if we see them and sink them, and we're going
英国人已经对德国实施了海军封锁，基本上关闭了北海，因为他们希望让德国人挨饿以求屈服。面对这种情况，大海军上将提尔皮茨和参谋长雨果·冯·波尔对德皇和他的总理贝特曼·霍尔维格说，我们能不能请放弃这些所谓的过时的巡洋舰规则，我们能不能拥抱所谓的“无限制潜艇战”？换句话说，不择手段。我们只要看到你们的商船就会攻击并击沉它们，我们要
to drive you off the seas of the world. And the Kaiser and his Chancellor, Bethmann-Holveg, said, no, we don't want to do this, because this will massively antagonize the United States, which obviously controls a lot of the merchant ships that are going hither and thither to Britain, and it might even bring the United States into the war. So there's a lot of dithering, but then in the beginning of February 1915, Paul persuades the Chancellor, Tehrbalt, Bettenholyovig, to give it a go. And he says, do you know what? I'm confident that we can destroy British merchant shipping with just 20 U-boats. That's all it will take.
把你们赶出世界海洋。而德皇和他的总理贝特曼·霍尔维格说，不，我们不想这样做，因为这会极大地激怒美国，美国显然控制着许多往返于英国的商船，这甚至可能把美国卷入战争。所以有很多犹豫不决，但在1915年2月初，波尔说服了总理贝特曼·霍尔维格尝试一下。他说，你知道吗？我有信心我们只需要20艘U型潜艇就能摧毁英国的商船。只需要这么多。
And the Chancellor says, well, what about the Americans? And you're not worried about the Americans? No, we're not worried about the Americans. Because we'll advertise this. We'll tell everybody we'll doing it. And we will strike really hard at the beginning. And that will have a deterrent effect. Basically, neutral shipping will stay away anyway.
而总理说，那么美国人呢？你不担心美国人吗？不，我们不担心美国人。因为我们会宣传这一点。我们会告诉所有人我们在这样做。而且我们会在开始时进行猛烈打击。那将产生威慑作用。基本上，中立国的航运无论如何都会远离。
They'll be so frightened that we will sink them. And actually, this is, and now this is very controversial, what the Germans say is, actually, if we did hit a passenger ship so much the better, it'll be a massive story and it will be the perfect deterrent. Because sure, a lot of lives will be lost, but that will drive all neutral shipping off the seas and basically Britain will be isolated and will be able to starve them out. The Kaiser, great friend of the rest of history, of course, some poor behaviour in his past. I think we can all agree on that, so not perfect.
他们会因为我们击沉他们而感到害怕。实际上，这是——现在这非常有争议——德国人所说的是，实际上，如果我们确实击中了一艘客轮，那就更好了，这将是一个巨大的新闻，它将是完美的威慑。因为当然，许多生命会丧失，但这会将所有中立国的航运赶出海洋，基本上英国将被孤立，我们将能够让他们挨饿。德皇，当然是历史之友的好朋友，过去有一些糟糕的行为。我想我们都可以同意这一点，所以并不完美。
But a man who always Basically his bark is a lot worse than his bite Isn't it? So he's against this? He's against this. He says, I don't like the sound of this at all. Because he's a man of humanity and peace.
但他是一个总是——基本上他的叫声比他的咬人要厉害得多，不是吗？所以他反对这一点？他反对这一点。他说，我一点也不喜欢这个主意。因为他是一个人道主义者和热爱和平的人。
He's a great humanitarian. Typical of the Kaiser. He's against it, but he doesn't get his way. You know, he's by this point already in the war he's becoming a bit of a figurehead, frankly. So Paul gets his way
他是一位伟大的人道主义者。德皇的典型表现。他反对它，但他没有如愿。你知道，到战争的这个时候，坦率地说，他已经成为一个傀儡了。所以波尔如愿以偿，
and on the 4th of February 1915, the Imperial German Gazette publishes this ominous announcement. The waters around Great Britain and Ireland, I don't know why he's doing a French accent, but anyway, are hereby declared to be a war zone. From February the 18th onwards, every enemy merchant vessel encountered in this zone will be destroyed, and it will not always be possible to avert the danger thereby threatened to the crew and passengers. Neutral vessels will also run a risk in the war zone, and it may not always be possible to prevent attacks on enemy ships from harming neutral ships. So in other words, the warning is pretty explicit. Don't go into the war zone, which is the waters around Britain and Ireland.
1915年2月4日，德意志帝国公报发布了这一不祥的公告。大不列颠和爱尔兰周围的水域——我不知道他为什么用法国口音，但无论如何——特此宣布为战区。从2月18日起，在该区域遇到的每一艘敌方商船都将被摧毁，并且并不总是能够避免由此对船员和乘客造成的危险。中立船只在该战区也将面临风险，并且并不总是能够防止对敌方船只的攻击伤害到中立船只。所以换句话说，警告非常明确。不要进入战区，也就是英国和爱尔兰周围的水域。
And so now the U-boat campaign is on in earnest. So often, ever since their defeat and the Battle of the Marn, the Germans are so conscious of the urgency of this that it pushes them into more extreme measures. So this is basically the nautical equivalent of using gas. Yeah, exactly. Or shooting Belgians. That's exactly what it is.
所以现在U型潜艇战役正式开始了。所以经常，自从他们在马恩河战役中失败以来，德国人对这种紧迫性非常清醒，以至于这迫使他们采取更极端的措施。所以这基本上相当于航海版的毒气战。是的，完全正确。或者枪杀比利时人。这正是它的本质。
You know, we're in a terrible hurry. Time is against us. We need to crack on. Be ruthless. Can't make an omelet without breaking smegs. Exactly. Their overall submarine supremo is a guy called Herman Bauer. He says to his U-boat commanders, come on, be really ruthless, strike without warning.
你知道，我们非常匆忙。时间对我们不利。我们需要继续前进。要无情。不打破鸡蛋就做不成煎蛋卷。完全正确。他们的潜艇总指挥官是一个叫赫尔曼·鲍尔的人。他告诉他的U型潜艇指挥官，来吧，要非常无情，在没有警告的情况下进行打击。
Terror is great. Drive merchant shipping off the seas. This is what we're going to do. Like a lot of the sort of Germans wheezes, this is flawed from the beginning because they've been massively over-optimistic. There have only 29 U-boats, many of which are barely operational. And they do sink quite a few ships. So they sink on average about two ships a day. But this is just a tiny, tiny fraction of the total of British merchant shipping.
恐怖是伟大的。把商船赶出海洋。这就是我们要做的。像许多德国人的诡计一样，这从一开始就是有缺陷的，因为他们过于乐观了。他们只有29艘U型潜艇，其中许多几乎无法运作。他们确实击沉了不少船只。所以他们平均每天击沉大约两艘船。但这只是英国商船总数中极小极小的一部分。
Because thousands and thousands are coming in all the time. Yeah, not remotely enough to affect Britain's economic strength. And the reputational cost is very high. So the first few months of 1915, they sink a tanker. They sink some Swedish ships, some Dutch ships, then two Greek ships in April. very bad for Germany's reputation with neutral countries. And then there's a very controversial incident on the 28th of March,
因为成千上万的船只一直在涌入。是的，远不足以影响英国的经济实力。而且声誉成本非常高。所以1915年的头几个月，他们击沉了一艘油轮。他们击沉了一些瑞典船只，一些荷兰船只，然后在4月击沉了两艘希腊船只。这对德国在中立国中的声誉非常不利。然后3月28日发生了一个非常有争议的事件，
when they chase down a British cargo liner called the Falaba. This is U28. And U28 actually gives the crew and passengers of the falaba 10 minutes to get off. It says you've got 10 minutes to get off and then we'll sink you. The evacuation is a bit of a shambles and takes longer than 10 minutes. The U-boat commander, for various reasons, loses patience, and fires a single torpedo. This sinks the ship and capsizes some of the lifeboats
当他们追击一艘名为“法拉巴号”的英国货轮时。这是U28。而U28实际上给了“法拉巴号”的船员和乘客10分钟的时间离开。它说你有10分钟时间离开，然后我们会击沉你。撤离有点混乱，花费的时间超过了10分钟。U型潜艇指挥官由于各种原因失去了耐心，并发射了一枚鱼雷。这击沉了船只并倾覆了一些已经进入水中的救生艇，
that have already got into the water and 111 people drowned or died of hypothermia. And disastrously for the Germans, one of them was an American, a man with the name Leon C. Thrasher. That's unreal. She's a school teacher. Surely, surely, at a boarding school,
111人溺水或死于体温过低。对德国人来说灾难性的是，其中一人是美国人，一个名叫莱昂·C·瑟拉舍的人。这太不真实了。她是一位学校老师。肯定，肯定，在一所寄宿学校，
at a boys boarding school that educated people who went on to run the State Department in Connecticut or something. All called Kermit or whatever. Yeah, exactly. Woodrow Wilson was outraged at the loss of Leon C thrasher. And he sent a note of complaint to the Germans. But a noted complaint was all he sent.
在一所培养了后来在康涅狄格州管理国务院的人的男子寄宿学校。都叫克米特之类的。是的，完全正确。伍德罗·威尔逊对莱昂·C·瑟拉舍的死亡感到愤怒。他给德国人发了一封抗议信。但一封抗议信就是他所发送的全部内容。
He didn't make a huge hullabaloo and a great protest about it. And that's because his Secretary of State, who's William Jennings Bryan, a kind of prairie populist and relative isolationist. They don't want to provoke the Germans and get into a sort of big international incident with them. And they say, well, maybe this was. was an accident, you know, maybe the Germans surely wouldn't do this again. So, that's happened. That was on the 28th of March. All this time, the Lusitania has been sailing back and forth
他没有对此大惊小怪，也没有进行大规模抗议。这是因为他的国务卿，威廉·詹宁斯·布莱恩，一个草原民粹主义者和相对的孤立主义者。他们不想激怒德国人并陷入某种重大的国际事件中。他们说，好吧，也许这只是一个意外，你知道，也许德国人肯定不会再这样做了。所以，事情发生了。那是3月28日。所有这些时间，卢西塔尼亚号一直在往返航行
between Liverpool and New York. And Cunard know that, you know, the rules of the game have changed since the Germans issued that warning. And just to be clear for people, because perhaps we haven't made it, this is a British company, it's a British ship. It's a not merely a British ship. It's a ship of which the British are very proud. Very proud. Yeah, because the race to control the sort of Atlantic passenger trade had been a big story in the 1900s, as with Titanic. Cunard's directors told the ship,
在利物浦和纽约之间。卡纳德航运公司知道，你知道，自从德国人发出那个警告以来，游戏规则已经改变了。为了让人们清楚，因为也许我们还没有说明，这是一家英国公司，这是一艘英国船。它不仅仅是一艘英国船。这是一艘英国人非常自豪的船。非常自豪。是的，因为控制大西洋客运贸易的竞赛在1900年代是一个大故事，就像泰坦尼克号一样。卡纳德的董事们告诉这艘船，
don't fly flags in the war zone. They have these sort of very distinctive red funnels, the Cunard ships, the Cunard liners. And they say, please paint your red funnels gray. So it'll be harder for enemy ships to spot you as you're crossing. I mean, I have to be honest, that would not reassure me if I was planning to take a ship across the Atlantic. But this thing is, if you wanted to cross the Atlantic, this is the only way you can go. I'd just stay. Well, if you were invited to do some
不要在战区悬挂旗帜。他们有这些非常独特的红色烟囱，卡纳德船只，卡纳德邮轮。他们说，请把你们的红色烟囱漆成灰色。这样敌方船只在你们横渡时就更难发现你们了。我的意思是，我必须诚实地说，如果我计划乘船横渡大西洋，那并不能让我感到安心。但问题是，如果你想横渡大西洋，这是你唯一能走的路。我只是待着。嗯，如果你被邀请去参加一些
corporate speaking event with your gramophone-based podcast in New York in 1950s, I do it by telegram. Oh, you do it by telegram? Very good. Just send telegrams. You do it remotely? Yeah, I would. Superb. That's what the Lusitania is doing. Now, meanwhile, in Germany, the head of the Admiralty staff says to the Kaiser, the campaign is going much too slowly. Like we've obviously, you know, we've started too slowly this U-boat campaign. We should act much more ruthlessly. We should stop giving passengers ships. We're still giving passengerships warning. We should strike from the deep silently and lethally. The Germans are very conscious that if this happens, again, there will be a diplomatic incident with the Americans. But it's important,
企业演讲活动，带着你的留声机播客在1950年代的纽约，我会通过电报做。哦，你通过电报做？非常好。只是发送电报。你远程做？是的，我会。极好。这就是卢西塔尼亚号正在做的事情。现在，与此同时，在德国，海军参谋长对德皇说，战役进行得太慢了。就像我们显然，你知道，我们开始得太慢了，这个U型潜艇战役。我们应该更无情地行动。我们应该停止给客轮警告。我们仍然在给客轮警告。我们应该从深处悄无声息且致命地打击。德国人非常清楚，如果这种情况再次发生，将会与美国发生外交事件。但重要的是，
I think, to bear in mind. Everybody at this point, think, the Americans are absolutely useless and flimsy and weak. So, yeah, the Americans have no history of getting involved in European conflicts in this way. And people look at Woodrow Wilson and they say, you know, he's kind of reedy and academic. Yeah, he's got steel glasses. There's a Jimmy Carter side to him, I think, that people say, and the Germans actually say, they say in writing, all the Americans want, they will do anything to stay out to this war. They simply do not have the guts to fight.
我认为要记住。每个人在这一点上都认为，美国人绝对是无用的、脆弱的和软弱的。所以，是的，美国人没有以这种方式卷入欧洲冲突的历史。人们看着伍德罗·威尔逊，他们说，你知道，他有点虚弱和学术化。是的，他戴着钢丝眼镜。我认为他身上有一种吉米·卡特的一面，人们说，而德国人实际上说，他们书面说，美国人想要的一切，他们会做任何事情来远离这场战争。他们根本没有战斗的胆量。
Might they have been slightly more careful if it had been Teddy Roosevelt, say, or someone of that ilk in the White House? Teddy Roosevelt has gutted that the Americans aren't fighting in the First World War. He loves a war, doesn't he? He loves a war. He loves two things, Teddy Roosevelt. He loves a war, and he loves Oliver Cromwell. Well, it makes sense.
如果白宫里是泰迪·罗斯福或者那种类型的人，他们会不会稍微小心一点？泰迪·罗斯福对美国没有参加第一次世界大战感到非常愤怒。他喜欢战争，不是吗？他喜欢战争。他喜欢两件事，泰迪·罗斯福。他喜欢战争，他喜欢奥利弗·克伦威尔。嗯，这说得通。
Doesn't he like hunting as well? Bears. Well, he's the father of the teddy bear, isn't he? This is a side issue. But I think it's important because that presents Wilson as the slightly ineffectual man of peace that he will prove himself to be. In due course. A man of war and of useless treaty making.
他不也喜欢打猎吗？熊。嗯，他是泰迪熊之父，不是吗？这是一个旁支问题。但我认为这很重要，因为它将威尔逊呈现为他最终将证明的那种稍微无效的和平主义者。在适当的时候。一个战争和无用条约制定的人。
The 17th of April, the Lusitania leaves Liverpool, and it crosses the Atlantic, east to west, without incident, and a week later in New York, so the 24th, it arrives in New York Harbor. And it's due to return on the 1st of May. Now, meanwhile, the German ambassador in Washington, who's a man called Johann Heinrich von Bernstorff, he is very worried that the Americans are underestimating the dangers of all this. and he decides he's going to put an official warning in the American press.
4月17日，卢西塔尼亚号离开利物浦，它横渡大西洋，从东向西，没有发生意外，一周后在纽约，也就是24日，它抵达纽约港。它定于5月1日返回。现在，与此同时，德国驻华盛顿大使，一个叫约翰·海因里希·冯·伯恩斯托夫的人，他非常担心美国人低估了所有这些危险。他决定要在美国媒体上发布一个官方警告。
So in American newspapers, the official warning, this advert runs in the American press, and it says, if you get on an Atlantic ship, be warned. You are travelling into a war zone and that British ships are legitimate targets. Travelers sailing in the war zone on the ships of Great Britain or her allies do so at their own risk. Well, I've got two questions. one is, are there American liners? And if there are, why aren't people just going on the American liners? And the second question is, is the Lusitania,
所以在美国报纸上，官方警告，这个广告在美国媒体上刊登，它说，如果你登上大西洋船只，请注意。你正在前往一个战区，英国船只是合法目标。在英国或其盟国的船只上在战区航行的旅客需自行承担风险。好吧，我有两个问题。一个是，有美国邮轮吗？如果有，为什么人们不只是乘坐美国邮轮？第二个问题是，卢西塔尼亚号，
because it's the most famous British liner, a prize in and of itself? And so therefore, do the U-boats know it's coming and are they looking out for it? Okay, two interesting questions. So first of all, interestingly, and for reasons that I don't know the answer to, American ships don't seem to have been big rivals
因为它最著名的英国邮轮，本身就是一个奖品吗？所以因此，U型潜艇知道它要来并且在寻找它吗？好的，两个有趣的问题。所以首先，有趣的是，由于我不知道答案的原因，美国船只似乎并没有成为大西洋邮轮业务的巨大竞争对手。
for the ocean liner business. So at this point, it's all the Germans, some Dutch ships, but also, but obviously British ships. But you don't really hear much mention of American ocean liners. So I guess there must be smaller American boats, but not big, luxurious ocean liners of this kind. So that's your first answer. And the second answer, I forgot what the question was.
所以在这个时候，全是德国人，一些荷兰船只，但也，但显然是英国船只。但你真的没听到多少关于美国远洋客轮的提及。所以我猜一定有更小的美国船只，但不是这种大型、豪华的远洋客轮。所以这是你的第一个答案。第二个答案，我忘了问题是什么了。
What was the question? Would the Germans consciously be looking out for the Lusitania because it would constitute a massive prize? No, I don't think so. I think, well, there are tons of conspiracy theories about whether the Lusitania was deliberately targeted or whether, in fact, the British were actually secretly controlling the whole thing. Most of those conspiracy theories, I think, are rubbish. I think the Germans are aware that the Lusitania exists.
问题是什么？德国人会因为卢西塔尼亚号构成巨大的奖品而有意识地寻找它吗？不，我不这么认为。我想，嗯，关于卢西塔尼亚号是否被故意针对，或者实际上英国人是否在秘密控制整个事情，有成吨的阴谋论。我认为大多数这些阴谋论都是垃圾。我认为德国人意识到卢西塔尼亚号的存在。
It's salient at this time. It's a big ship and it's the fastest ship. But I don't think they set out deliberately to target this particular ship. Although later on it was sort of claim that they did. But I don't think that's the case at all. There's no evidence for it. As we will see, they end up coming across it by chance rather than by design. Though this is controversial, if you go onto the internet, I mean, Tom, you could spend,
它在当时很突出。它是一艘大船，而且是速度最快的船。但我不认为他们故意针对这艘特定的船。尽管后来有人声称他们这样做了。但我不认为情况是这样。没有证据支持这一点。正如我们将看到的，他们最终是偶然遇到它，而不是通过设计。尽管这很有争议，如果你上网，我的意思是，汤姆，你可以花，
I know you've got better, I think you've actually got better internet discipline than I have, but you could easily lose days of your life falling down lucetania rabbit holes. I imagine we're going to be coming to the conspiracy theory, so I might wait till then. This ambassador has prepared this advert, but just one small thing. for various humdrum technical reasons, the advert is delayed. So the advert doesn't actually appear in American newspapers. It doesn't first appear until Friday the 30th of April, which is the day before the Lusitania is due to leave New York.
我知道你已经变得更好了，我觉得你现在的互联网自律能力比我强，但你很容易在卢西塔尼亚号的各种深坑里浪费掉生命中的几天。我想我们之后会谈到阴谋论，所以我可能等到那时候再说。这位大使准备了这则广告，但有一件小事，由于各种枯燥的技术原因，广告被推迟了。所以这则广告实际上并没有出现在美国报纸上。它直到4月30日星期五才首次刊登，也就是卢西塔尼亚号预定离开纽约的前一天。
And indeed, some papers are actually printing it the next day, the Saturday, the day the passengers are boarding. You wouldn't want to see that, would you? No, like what's in the paper today? Oh, an advert telling me that if I get on this ship, I'll probably die. So we come to the day of the Lusitania's departure. That's Saturday the 1st of May. And it's due to leave at 10 o'clock in the morning from Manhattan's Pier 54. The Lusitania is still only eight years old. So it's one of the world's great ocean liners. And as you would expect, it's a tremendous spectacle. She's been painted gray at the funnels, but still a spectacular site. Nine decks, 31,000 tons, 800 feet long, almost. There's a huge hustle and bustle as everybody's boarding. That said, because of the war and the inevitable fears, so as you said, you know, who would be crossing the Atlantic. The answer is a lot fewer people than normal. There are 1,264 passengers on the Lusitania and 702 crew, so a total of 1,966,
事实上，有些报纸是在第二天，也就是星期六，乘客登船的那天刊登的。你肯定不想看到那个，对吧？不，就像今天报纸上写了什么？哦，一则广告告诉我，如果我上了这艘船，我可能会死。于是我们来到了卢西塔尼亚号出发的日子。那是5月1日星期六。它定于上午10点从曼哈顿的54号码头出发。卢西塔尼亚号当时只有八岁，所以它是世界上最伟大的远洋客轮之一。正如你所预料的那样，它是一个巨大的奇观。它的烟囱被漆成了灰色，但依然是一个壮观的景象。九层甲板，31000吨，近800英尺长。每个人都在登船，现场一片繁忙。话虽如此，由于战争和不可避免的恐惧，正如你所说，谁还会横渡大西洋呢？答案是比平时少得多的人。卢西塔尼亚号上有1264名乘客和702名船员，总共1966人，
let's say just under 2,000. But that is less than half the Lusitania's total capacity. And of those people who are on the ship, the vast majority are British, there are lots of Canadians, and there are 159 citizens of the United States of America. So that's the passengers, but more controversial, is the cargo. It was very common on transatlantic voyages for ships to carry cargo that could be put to military use. The Lucitania is carrying copper wire, machine parts, these kinds of things in the hold,
我们说不到2000人。但这还不到卢西塔尼亚号总载客量的一半。在船上的这些人中，绝大多数是英国人，有很多加拿大人，还有159名美利坚合众国公民。这就是乘客，但更具争议的是货物。在跨大西洋航行中，船只携带可用于军事用途的货物是非常普遍的。卢西塔尼亚号的货舱里装载着铜线、机器零件之类的东西，
huge quantities of sort of wire and stuff that clearly could be used by arms manufacturers. And are they carrying any weapons or ammunition? The short answer is yes, they are. They're carrying four million rounds of Remington.303 rifle ammunition. They're carrying a thousand cases of shrapnel-filled artillery shells. They're carrying 16 cases of percussion fuses. They're carrying tons and tons, 46 tons, in fact, of aluminium powder,
大量的电线之类的东西显然可以被军火制造商使用。那么他们携带武器或弹药了吗？简短的回答是，是的，他们携带了。他们携带了400万发雷明顿.303步枪弹药。他们携带了1000箱装满弹片的炮弹。他们携带了16箱引信。他们携带了成吨成吨的，实际上是46吨铝粉，
which is used for making explosives. And who sent this? American manufacturers. It's being bought. To the British Army? To British... Armaments manufacturers. Yeah, armaments manufacturers.
这种东西是用来制造炸药的。这是谁送的？美国制造商。这是被购买的。卖给英国军队？卖给英国……军火制造商。是的，军火制造商。
Exactly. British factories. Now, this is incredibly controversial. So later on, after the Lusitania sank, the Germans said, look at this. I mean, you're carrying war contraband. This is obviously war stuff.
没错。英国工厂。现在，这极具争议。所以后来，在卢西塔尼亚号沉没后，德国人说，看看这个。我的意思是，你们携带了战争违禁品。这显然是战争物资。
But the American government's position was, You know, this is not an arms trade between two nations. This is completely standard on transatlantic shipping. This is, and I quote, a private legal shipment of small arms. The rifle ammunition is the kind that would have gone back and forth between Britain and America during peacetime, and it can be used by private citizens, and it's continued in wartime as well. And in no way does this violate United States neutrality.
但美国政府的立场是，你知道，这不是两国之间的军火贸易。这在跨大西洋航运中是完全标准的。这，引用我的话，是一批私人的、合法的轻武器运输。这种步枪弹药是在和平时期英国和美国之间往来运输的那种，私人公民也可以使用，在战时也继续这样。这绝不违反美国的 neutrality（中立）。
And I think a fair-minded observer would surely say the Americans are stretching a point here. And the Germans, obviously, are not being unreasonable in saying you are shipping military material. The one thing I would say, though, is that this is no way a secret. Everybody knows that Kuhna are doing this. It has been well known for months that ocean liners carry cargo like this. and the British and American position is, well, it doesn't really matter, because the big issue is the safety of the passengers. And you, the Germans, as supposedly decent civilized people, you should put the safety of the passengers first. And basically, you know, you should do everything in your power to save their lives.
我认为一个公正的观察者肯定会说美国人在这里有点强词夺理。而德国人显然在说你们在运输军事物资时并非不合理。不过，我要说的一点是，这绝不是什么秘密。每个人都知道卡纳德航运公司在这样做。几个月来，远洋客轮携带这类货物已是众所周知的事。而英国和美国的立场是，好吧，这并不重要，因为大问题是乘客的安全。而你们，德国人，作为所谓的体面文明人，你们应该把乘客的安全放在第一位。基本上，你知道，你们应该尽一切努力挽救他们的生命。
And the fact that the ship is also carrying munitions is neither here or there. I mean, it's kind of basically using civilians as human shields to kind of protect military, targets. I think that's a pretty fair assessment. I mean, I don't want to sound unpatriotic. Yeah, you would have, if you had made that assessment in an article in the morning post in 1915, there would have been a mob outside your house. Yeah, white feathers all round. Yeah, white feathers, exactly. But I think it's completely reasonable. I think if you're, if there are German, this to this podcast, they would definitely be raising an eyebrow at this and saying, come on. I mean, I don't think it's reasonable that you're transporting all this stuff and pretending it's just a
而船上还载有弹药的事实无关紧要。我的意思是，这基本上是把平民当作人盾来保护军事目标。我认为这是一个相当公平的评估。我的意思是，我不想听起来不爱国。是的，如果你在1915年的《晨邮报》上发表那样的评估，你家门外就会有一群暴徒。是的，到处都是白羽毛。是的，白羽毛，没错。但我认为这是完全合理的。我想如果这期播客有德国听众，他们肯定会对此挑眉，说，得了吧。我的意思是，我不认为你们运输所有这些东西却假装它只是一艘
civilian ship. Anyway, the passengers are, a lot of them are very anxious. the German warning has now appeared in 50 American newspapers. Some of them ran it on the Friday, some on the Saturday morning. And one paper very famously, you can see Clippings Online, actually runs it next to a Cunard advert for the Lusitania. So next to each of this like, sail the Lusitania. And next to it is that thing saying, if you sail on the Lusitania, we were getting it. Basically. There's a nice book on the sort of very colorful book on the Lusitania by Greg King and Penny Wilson, which came out about 10 years ago.
民用船只，这是合理的。总之，乘客们，他们中的很多人非常焦虑。德国的警告现在已经出现在50家美国报纸上。有些在周五刊登，有些在周六早上。其中一份报纸非常出名，你可以在网上看到剪报，它实际上把它印在了一则卡纳德公司卢西塔尼亚号广告的旁边。所以就在这旁边写着，乘坐卢西塔尼亚号。而旁边就是那条说，如果你乘坐卢西塔尼亚号，我们就会击沉它。基本上就是这样。格雷格·金和彭妮·威尔逊大约10年前出了一本关于卢西塔尼亚号的非常生动的书。
And this has loads of nice stories about passengers discussing the warning as they're boarding the ship. So there's a group that we'll come back to. There's a family called The Pearls. And they have a nanny called Alice Lines. We'll come back to them in the second half. And Alice Lines is British. She's very young. She brings it up with the Pearl.
里面有很多关于乘客在登船时讨论警告的好故事。所以有一个我们稍后会回到的群体。有一个叫珀尔的家庭。他们有一个保姆叫爱丽丝·莱恩斯。我们会在下半部分回到他们身上。爱丽丝·莱恩斯是英国人。她很年轻。她向珀尔一家提起了这件事。
She's very anxious about it. And Mrs. Pearl says to her, take no notice, dear. It is just propaganda. There's a suffragette called Margaret McWorth. And she's boarding the ship with her father. Viscount Ronda. And she remembers later, she's a survivor, she remembered later that the passengers were discussing the warnings and a lot of them are very angry, feeling ran strong and that we should be
她对此非常焦虑。珀尔太太对她说，别理会，亲爱的。那只是宣传。有一位叫玛格丽特·麦克沃思的妇女参政论者。她和她的父亲朗达子爵一起登船。她后来回忆说，她是一位幸存者，她记得乘客们在讨论这些警告，很多人非常愤怒，情绪强烈，认为我们已经在预订了船票之后，不应该被德国的威胁赶出我们自己的船。这就是
driven off our own boat by German threats after we'd already booked our passage. There is. The authentic voice of the British consumer. Yeah. I've paid good money for these tickets. So to send us the warning now is disgraceful. Because presumably there wouldn't be travel insurance. I mean, you couldn't catch a ticket because of that.
英国消费者的真实声音。是的。我为这些票付了真金白银。所以现在给我们发警告是可耻的。因为大概不会有旅行保险。我的意思是，你不可能因为那个就退票。
I mean, well, maybe there is, I don't know, but imagine trying to make a claim into travel insurance in 1915. It's difficult enough now. Doing it then would be a nightmare. And one of the passengers, interestingly, has had a very specific warning. And this is, we love a millionaire, a doomed millionaire traveling on a boat. We so do. I'll say it's our signature. Yeah.
我的意思是，好吧，也许有，我不知道，但想象一下在1915年尝试向旅行保险索赔。现在已经够难了。那时候做这件事简直是一场噩梦。有趣的是，其中一位乘客收到过一个非常具体的警告。这就是，我们喜欢百万富翁，一个乘坐船只的注定失败的百万富翁。我们太喜欢了。我会说这是我们的标志。是的。
This is a 37-year-old millionaire called Alfred Gwynne Vanderbilt. And he is of the Vanderbilt Shipping and Railroad Dynasty. Vanderbilt is an extremely rich man and he was generally described as a sportsman for his love of elite sport like you Tom but his choice of sports were probably a little different from yours because his sports were fox hunting and carriage racing kind of like Prince Philip.
这是一个37岁的百万富翁，名叫阿尔弗雷德·格温·范德比尔特。他来自范德比尔特航运和铁路王朝。范德比尔特是一个极其富有的人，他通常被描述为一名运动员，因为他热爱像你汤姆那样的精英运动，但他选择的运动可能和你有点不同，因为他的运动是猎狐和马车赛，有点像菲利普亲王。
Like Prince Philip, exactly. Now before he gets on the boat that morning he gets a telegram that says to him, do not get on the Lusitania. The Lusitania is going to be torpedoed. And it's signed with the single word Morte. death. I mean, this is very, very reminiscent, Dominic, of what you might call the Titanic mythos. I would call it Titanic Mythos. Yeah, I would. I absolutely would. The trouble with this story is I've looked into it, and I can't find where it comes from. And I'm curious about
像菲利普亲王，没错。现在在他那天早上上船之前，他收到了一封电报，上面写着，不要上卢西塔尼亚号。卢西塔尼亚号会被鱼雷击中。上面只签了一个词：Morte。死亡。我的意思是，这非常非常让人想起，多米尼克，你可能称之为泰坦尼克号神话的东西。我会称之为泰坦尼克号神话。是的，我会。我绝对会。这个故事的问题在于我研究过它，但我找不到它来自哪里。我很好奇
how anyone would know, because Alfred Gwynne Vanderbilt, we described him as a doomed millionaire. So, spoiler alert, he's not telling his story in the 1930s. Maybe he told his valet and the Valley survived? I don't know. Maybe. Hey, look, Dominic, it's a mythos. You don't get, don't dig down too hard. Then one knew the Lusitania was going to be torpedoed. So I think this was either a jape from one of his posh friends or somebody made this story up and now it's just told and retold in histories ever since. On the key side is the QNR general agent in New York, who's a man called Charles Sumner. And he gives a press conference. He says to the press, there is no risk whatsoever. So when you hear that getting on a tip.
谁会知道，因为阿尔弗雷德·格温·范德比尔特，我们称他为注定失败的百万富翁。所以，剧透预警，他没有在20世纪30年代讲述他的故事。也许他告诉了他的男仆，而男仆幸存了下来？我不知道。也许吧。嘿，听着，多米尼克，这是一个神话。你不要深究。那时没人知道卢西塔尼亚号会被鱼雷击中。所以我认为这要么是他那些时髦朋友开的一个玩笑，要么是有人编造了这个故事，现在它在历史中被一遍又一遍地讲述。在码头上是卡纳德公司在纽约的总代理，一个叫查尔斯·萨姆纳的人。他举行了新闻发布会。他对媒体说，没有任何风险。所以当你听到那个上船的提示时。
They couldn't have an elephant at this dist. Right. Don't get on that ship. Lucitania, he says, it's too fast for any submarine. No German vessel of war can get near her. And the same message comes from the ship's captain. So we love a sea dog on the show.
他们不可能在这个距离有一头大象。对。别上那艘船。卢西塔尼亚号，他说，它太快了，任何潜艇都追不上。没有德国战舰能靠近它。同样的信息也来自船长。所以我们喜欢节目里的海狗。
But this captain, the captain of the Lucitania, is not a great charmer, William Turner. He's seen his very gruff. He's not like Captain Smith and the Titanic, one of his greatest mariners. The only really interesting thing about him, his nickname is Bowler Bill, because every time he gets a new ship,
但这位船长，卢西塔尼亚号的船长，威廉·特纳，并不是一个很有魅力的人。他看起来非常粗鲁。他不像泰坦尼克号上的史密斯船长，那是他最伟大的水手之一。关于他唯一真正有趣的事情是，他的绰号是“圆顶礼帽比尔”，因为每次他得到一艘新船，
he buys a new bowler hat, which he wears. Do you know, I've been hard on Captain Smith, as you'll know. Yeah, yeah. But I don't think that you should wear a bowler hat if you're captaining an ocean-going liner. I think you should wear your nautical hat like Captain Smith did. If I was getting on a ship and I saw three things, one, an advert telling me that if I get on a ship,
他都会买一顶新的圆顶礼帽，并戴着它。你知道吗，我对史密斯船长很严厉，正如你所知。是的，是的。但我不认为如果你在指挥一艘远洋客轮，你应该戴圆顶礼帽。我认为你应该像史密斯船长那样戴你的航海帽。如果我要上一艘船，我看到了三件事，第一，一则广告告诉我，如果我上一艘船，
I will probably be sunk. If I saw that, if I heard a man from the company running the ships, saying, this ship is unsinkable, I probably wouldn't get on. And then if I saw the captain wearing an inappropriate hat, that would massively put, that's a massive red flag, no? It really is, isn't it? Yeah.
我可能会沉没。如果我看到了那个，如果我听到运营这些船的公司的人说，这艘船是永不沉没的，我可能不会上。然后如果我看到船长戴着一顶不合适的帽子，那会是一个巨大的危险信号，不是吗？确实是这样，不是吗？是的。
Captain, whatever his name is, Bowler Bill, Captain Turner, he tells the press as well, we should be going faster than any submarine can travel. They're not likely to sneak up on us. The Titanic is unsinkable. Right. So anyway, the voyage, departure is delayed. They have to wait because there's people coming from another boat, and at midday they finally get underway.
船长，不管他叫什么名字，圆顶礼帽比尔，特纳船长，他也告诉媒体，我们应该比任何潜艇能行驶的速度都要快。他们不太可能悄悄靠近我们。泰坦尼克号是永不沉没的。对。所以无论如何，航行，出发被推迟了。他们不得不等待，因为有从另一艘船过来的人，中午他们终于起航了。
There are people waving handkerchiefs, cameras, all the usual stuff. Now, meanwhile, the day before, a submarine called U20, commanded by Captain Leitnant Walthershviger, has set off from North Germany, and it's gone across the North Sea, around the top of Scotland, then down the west coast of Ireland, and then U20 is going to come back into the Irish Sea from the south. And the Admiralty in Britain have been tracking her using intercepted German messages. They're decoding German messages. But this is so secret that they've decoded. They have this room 40, it's called, in the Admiralty, the decoding room.
有人挥舞手帕，有摄像机，所有通常的东西。现在，与此同时，前一天，一艘由瓦尔特·施维格海军上尉指挥的U20潜艇，已经从德国北部出发，穿过了北海，绕过苏格兰顶部，然后沿着爱尔兰西海岸南下，然后U20将从南部回到爱尔兰海。英国海军部一直在使用截获的德国信息追踪它。他们在破译德国信息。但这太机密了，他们破译了。他们在海军部有一个所谓的40号房间，即破译室。
And it's so secret that the warnings are not being widely distributed. So it's like Bletchley Park in the Second World War. Like Enigma in the Second World War, exactly. On the 5th of May, so this is after the Lusitania has set off, U-20 intercepts a merchant ship called the Earl of Latham off the coast of County Cork. And that evening, the Royal Navy sends a warning to all ships, submarines active off the south coast of Ireland. On the 6th of May, U-20 intercepts a British steamer called the SS candidate
这太机密了，以至于警告没有被广泛分发。所以就像第二次世界大战中的布莱切利园一样。就像第二次世界大战中的恩尼格玛密码机，没错。5月5日，也就是卢西塔尼亚号出发后，U20在科克郡海岸外截获了一艘名为“拉瑟姆伯爵号”的商船。那天晚上，皇家海军向所有船只发出警告，爱尔兰南海岸有潜艇活动。5月6日，U20截获了一艘名为“SS候选人号”的英国汽船
off the coast of County Wexford, and then another ship, the SS Centurium. And in each case, the crew of those ships is able to escape before the U-boat sinks them. If the U-boats are operating off the south coast of Ireland, there's no thought of going kind of around the north and to Liverpool that way? You could do that, but there's no reason to believe that there aren't submarines there. I mean, the submarines are all around the British and Irish waters.
在韦克斯福德郡海岸外，然后是另一艘船，SS森图里翁号。在每种情况下，这些船的船员都能在U型潜艇击沉他们之前逃脱。如果U型潜艇在爱尔兰南海岸活动，有没有想过绕过北部去利物浦？你可以那样做，但没有理由相信那里就没有潜艇。我的意思是，潜艇遍布英国和爱尔兰海域。
So all this time, the Lusitania has been steaming east. And that morning, the 6th, she is about 860 miles west, and she is well clear of the war zone. But by the evening of the 6th, she is less than 400 miles from the war zone. And about 8 o'clock that night, Captain Turner gets two messages. Submarines are still active off the south coast of Ireland and, quote, avoid headlands, pass harbours at full speed, steer mid-channel course. And so we come to dawn on the fatal morning the 7th of May, 1915. It is very foggy.
所以这段时间，卢西塔尼亚号一直在向东航行。那天早上，6号，它在西边约860英里处，远离战区。但到了6号晚上，它距离战区不到400英里。那天晚上8点左右，特纳船长收到了两条信息。潜艇仍在爱尔兰南海岸活动，并且，引用，避开岬角，全速通过港口，走航道中间。于是我们来到了5月7日那个致命早晨的黎明，1915年。雾非常大。
Captain Turner posts extra lookouts and he slows his speed to just 15 knots and he sounds the foghorn. Now some passengers don't like this. They say, why would you sound the foghorn? You're drawing attention to our presence as we were approaching the war. zone. But he says, well, it's foggy. This is what you do. This is just how ship's sail. Because he's conscious that he's entering the war zone, he orders the 22 lifeboat swung out ready just in case. So, you know, he's thinking ahead. You wouldn't be reassuring, would it? Not terribly. At 10 o'clock, the fog begins to lift,
特纳船长安排了额外的了望员，并将速度减慢到仅15节，并鸣响了雾笛。现在有些乘客不喜欢这样。他们说，你为什么要鸣响雾笛？当我们接近战区时，你在引起人们对我们存在的注意。但他回答说，好吧，雾很大。这就是你们要做的。这就是船只航行的方式。因为他意识到自己正在进入战区，他下令将22艘救生艇摇出，以防万一。所以，你知道，他在未雨绸缪。这不会让人感到安心，对吧？不太会。10点钟，雾开始散去，
and as midday approaches, they've increased speed to 18 knots. It's a lovely, sunny, clear day. At 1152, so just before midday, they get another warning. from the Admiralty by Telegraph. U-boats active in southern part of Irish Channel. And then at 1 o'clock, another message. Submarine, five miles south of Cape Clear, proceeding west when sighted at 10 a.m. Now this is a false alarm.
随着中午临近，他们将速度提高到了18节。这是一个可爱、阳光明媚、晴朗的日子。11点52分，也就是中午之前，他们收到了另一条警告。来自海军部的电报。U型潜艇在爱尔兰海峡南部活动。然后1点钟，又一条信息。潜艇，在克利尔角以南五英里处，10点被发现时正在向西航行。现在这是一个虚假警报。
This is a false report. But it gives Turner the impression, because they are clear of that by this point, that they are past the danger. In fact, they're not past the danger. The U-boat is ahead of them. At this point, it's 1 o'clock. in the afternoon on 7th of May, the passengers can see the coast of Ireland in the distance.
这是一个虚假报告。但这给了特纳一种印象，因为他们此时已经远离了那里，他们已经过了危险区。事实上，他们并没有过危险区。U型潜艇在他们前面。此时是5月7日下午1点。乘客们可以看到远处的爱尔兰海岸。
And some of them have actually gathered on the port side of the ship, that's the left, to look out and to spot the coast of Ireland. So they're very close now. The voyage is almost over. Meanwhile, on U-20, Captain Leitnant Schfiger is running low on fuel, and he's got only three torpedoes left. He is at the end of his own voyage. And partly because of the fog, He has decided, let's call it a day and let us go back to base in Germany. And then at 20 minutes past one, his call to the conning tower, as it's called, of the U-boat. The lookout says, I've spotted something on the horizon. It looks like an enormous ocean liner.
他们中的一些人实际上聚集在船的左舷，也就是左侧，向外看并寻找爱尔兰海岸。所以他们现在离得很近了。航行即将结束。与此同时，在U20上，瓦尔特·施维格海军上尉的燃料不足，他只剩下三枚鱼雷了。他正处于自己航行的尽头。部分由于雾，他决定，算了吧，让我们回德国基地。然后1点20分，他呼叫U型潜艇的指挥塔。了望员说，我在地平线上发现了一些东西。看起来像一艘巨大的远洋客轮。
And Schfiger immediately orders the U-boat to dive. They dive to a depth of six fathoms, which is about 36 feet, and to head for the target. And so they head for the target. they go closer and closer and closer. It is now 140, and the Lusitania is approaching the old head of Kinsale, which is about 13 miles away, and Sviga is very close to his target now.
施维格立即下令U型潜艇下潜。他们下潜到六英寻的深度，大约36英尺，并向目标前进。于是他们向目标前进。他们越来越近，越来越近。现在是1点40分，卢西塔尼亚号正在接近老金塞尔角，距离大约13英里，施维格现在离他的目标非常近了。
And then to his horror, the Lusitania turns and turns away. He's gutted, he's lost the chance for this fantastic prize. And then, to his disbelief, the Lusitania turns very slightly again, back in range, back into his sight, and he breathes a massive sigh of relief. It is now 10 minutes past two. The Lusitania is finally in range, and on U-20, Volta Schviger gives the order to fire. My goodness. Will it hit? Will the Lusitania sink? Only one way to find out. Join us after the break.
然后令他惊恐的是，卢西塔尼亚号转向了，转开了。他很沮丧，他失去了这个绝佳奖品的机会。然后，令他难以置信的是，卢西塔尼亚号又稍微转了回来，回到了射程内，回到了他的视野中，他长长地松了一口气。现在是2点10分。卢西塔尼亚号终于进入了射程，在U20上，瓦尔特·施维格下达了开火命令。天哪。它会击中吗？卢西塔尼亚号会沉没吗？只有一个办法可以知道。休息后回来加入我们。
This episode is brought to you by the Times and by the Sunday Times. Now, if there is one thing, that history, and indeed Bob Dylan, teaches us it is that the times they are always are changing. And Dominic, I guess we're living in changing times now, what with America attacking Iran and oil crises. So do you think that the lessons of that for Kirstama are Rosie? So looking at the career of Edward Heath, for instance, who was prime minister in the previous oil crisis? It didn't work out brilliantly for Ted Heath, to be honest. Actually, he and is Darma, I think, are quite similar. They're from relatively humble backgrounds and there's a slight sense of floundering, which they have in common. But their bigger point is you never really
本集由《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》为您呈现。现在，如果说历史，实际上还有鲍勃·迪伦，教会了我们什么，那就是时代总是在变。多米尼克，我想我们现在生活在变化的时代，美国攻击伊朗和石油危机。所以你认为这对基尔·斯塔默来说是乐观的吗？比如看看爱德华·希思的职业生涯，他在之前的石油危机中担任首相？老实说，这对泰德·希思来说并没有产生辉煌的结果。实际上，我认为他和斯塔默相当相似。他们都来自相对卑微的背景，并且有一种共同的轻微挣扎感。但他们更大的观点是你永远不知道拐角处是什么，对吧？因为当你审视历史时，未来总是相当不确定的。但是，你知道，事实，它们不应该是确定的。当然，这就是《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》发挥作用的地方。
know what's around the corner, do you? Because when you look at history, the future is always pretty uncertain. But, you know, the facts, they shouldn't be uncertain. And that, of course, is where the Times and the Sunday Times come in. Yeah, and I would say that understanding the news is absolutely vital when you're navigating an increasingly uncertain and unpredictable world. So to subscribe to The Times and the Sunday Times, visit thetimes.com. The Madamy Holmes bike for brain health supporting Baycrest returns on May 31 for its fifth anniversary with a new start and finish at the Aga Khan Museum. Join thousands of cyclists as we take over the DVP and Gardner Expressway in support of dementia research and brain health.
是的，我会说在驾驭一个日益不确定和不可预测的世界时，了解新闻是绝对至关重要的。所以要订阅《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》，请访问thetimes.com。支持贝克雷斯特大脑健康的“马达米·霍姆斯自行车赛”将于5月31日回归，迎来五周年纪念，起点和终点设在阿迦汗博物馆。加入成千上万的骑行者，我们占领DVP和加德纳高速公路，以支持痴呆症研究和大脑健康。
Riders of all abilities are welcome, and both regular bikes and e-bikes can participate. Bring your friends, family or corporate team, and make an impact. Register today at fight for brainhealth.ca. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest of history, where it is 10 minutes past two on Friday, the 7th of May, 1915, and the German U-boat captain has just given order to fire on the ocean liner,
欢迎各种能力的骑手，普通自行车和电动自行车都可以参加。带上你的朋友、家人或企业团队，产生影响。今天就在fightforbrainhealth.ca注册。大家好，欢迎回到历史的其余部分，现在是1915年5月7日星期五下午2点10分，德国U型潜艇船长刚刚下达了向远洋客轮开火的命令，
Lusitania, and almost instantly on board the Lusitania, the 18-year-old lookout, who's a guy called Leslie Morton, spots a thin streak of foam speeding towards the ship, and that's nothing that you want to. see when you're a lookout in a time of war, is it? Not at all. So Morton shouts, torpedoes coming on the starboard side. Now, actually, he's wrong. There's just one torpedo, although this has given rise to yet more conspiracy theories. Morton said later, I saw the torpedo coming, a white streak about two
卢西塔尼亚号，几乎瞬间在卢西塔尼亚号上，18岁的了望员，一个叫莱斯利·莫顿的家伙，发现一条细细的泡沫条正向船只疾驰而来，在战争时期作为了望员，你可不想看到那个，对吧？一点也不。所以莫顿大喊，鱼雷从右舷袭来。现在，实际上，他错了。只有一枚鱼雷，尽管这引发了更多的阴谋论。莫顿后来回忆说，我看到鱼雷过来了，一条白色的条纹，在水面下约两
feet below the surface. It struck just below the bridge. There was a muffled explosion and a cloud of coal dust and steam shot up. Then almost instantly there came a second explosion, far greater, more shattering. The ship trembled like a living thing. Now, Schfiger, the guy who gave the order to fire, is watching from the periscope of U-20, and he records a very similar description in his ship's log. The torpedo hitting right behind the bridge
英尺处。它击中了桥楼下方。一声闷响，一股煤尘和蒸汽冲天而起。然后几乎瞬间传来了第二次爆炸，远比第一次更大，更具破坏力。船像一个活物一样颤抖。现在，施维格，那个下达开火命令的家伙，正从U20的潜望镜中观察，他在船的航海日志中记录了一个非常相似的描述。鱼雷击中了桥楼后面
was where he thought it hit, although he was wrong. An explosion, and then a second explosion. The ship stops immediately, he writes, and heals over to starboard very quickly, immersing simultaneously at the bow. And it's at this point, he said, the name Lusitania becomes visible in golden letters. And it is famous enough that this is really a big deal.
他认为它击中的地方，尽管他错了。一声爆炸，然后是第二次爆炸。船立即停止，他写道，并迅速向右舷倾斜，船头同时浸入水中。就在这时，他说，卢西塔尼亚号的名字以金色的字母显现出来。它足够出名，这确实是一件大事。
He'll think, yeah, this is a great kill. But I think up to this point, he didn't know it was the Lusitania. He just thought it's a bloody big ship. Anyway, this talk of a second explosion, very controversial for this reason. We mentioned all the ammunition and stuff that's being carried. But that was non-explosive. In other words, to pass the US sort of, you know, port authority regulations, you couldn't carry explosives on a ship that might blow up.
他会想，是的，这是一个伟大的战果。但我认为直到这一点，他都不知道那是卢西塔尼亚号。他只是认为那是一艘该死的大船。总之，关于第二次爆炸的说法，因为这个原因非常有争议。我们提到了所有正在运输的弹药之类的东西。但那是非爆炸性的。换句话说，为了通过美国港务局的规定，你不能在可能爆炸的船上携带炸药。
So it can't have been all this. So there's a conspiracy theory ever since that the Lusitania must have been carrying secret explosives not recorded in the kind of ships manifest or whatever. But I think this is bonkers. Most historians think this is bonkers. And what was actually happening was something to do with the boilers. It's always something to do with the boilers. isn't it? Same with Titanic.
所以不可能是所有这些。因此，自那时以来一直有一种阴谋论，认为卢西塔尼亚号一定携带了未记录在船只舱单或类似文件中的秘密炸药。但我认为这很疯狂。大多数历史学家认为这很疯狂。而实际上发生的事情与锅炉有关。总是与锅炉有关，不是吗？泰坦尼克号也是如此。
So this huge geyser of kind of water and shrapnel and smoke and debris erupts above the deck of the Lusitania. As one passenger said, it sounded like a million-ton hammer hitting a steam boiler 100 feet high. And immediately, Captain Turner, Bowler Bill, shouts to the quartermaster, he says, turn towards the Irish coast. But the ship has already lost control and the ship is not responding to the ship's wheel. Turner says put the engines into reverse. We need to stop the ship, but the ship is basically not responding it to anything now. Meanwhile, the wireless operator has already sent out an SOS. This is within moments of the ship being hit by the torpedo and he's transmitting the ship's position south of Kinsale on the coast of County Cork. Remember, the torpedo hit at 10 past 2. So at 214, the power fails and the whole of the ship is plunged into darkness. So the has failed. The electric lifts are shut down, and they're actually crew members who are heading up to the deck to launch the lifeboats who are trapped in the lifts. God. Oh, how awful. Already the starboard compartments of the ship are flooding badly. The ship is beginning to list
所以这股巨大的水、弹片、烟雾和碎片的喷泉在卢西塔尼亚号的甲板上喷发。正如一位乘客所说，听起来像一把百万吨重的锤子击中了100英尺高的蒸汽锅炉。特纳船长，“圆顶礼帽比尔”，立即对军需官大喊，他说，转向爱尔兰海岸。但船已经失去了控制，船对船舵没有反应。特纳说把引擎倒转。我们需要停船，但船基本上对任何东西都没有反应了。与此同时，无线电操作员已经发出了SOS。这是在船被鱼雷击中后的瞬间，他正在发送船只在科克郡海岸金塞尔以南的位置。记住，鱼雷在2点10分击中。所以2点14分，电力失效，整艘船陷入黑暗。所以电力失效了。电动电梯关闭了，实际上有船员正前往甲板去放下救生艇，他们被困在电梯里。天哪。哦，太可怕了。船的右舷舱室已经严重进水。船开始
to sort of tip towards starboard. The forecastle at the front of the ship is close to going under, so it's going down very, very quickly. And a minute later at 2.15, so this is five minutes after the torpedo hit, Captain Turner gives the order to abandon ship and to start launching the lifeboats. So some of this may sound reminiscent of the series we did about Titanic or the shows we did about Titanic in Ireland. The difference, though, is people who remember the Titanic series, the Titanic drama, what makes it so riveting is that it unfolds in some ways in slow motion. It's a slow puncture, isn't it?
向右舷倾斜。船头的艏楼快要沉没了，所以它下沉得非常非常快。一分钟后，也就是2点15分，即鱼雷击中五分钟后，特纳船长下令弃船并开始放下救生艇。所以其中一些听起来可能让人想起我们制作的关于泰坦尼克号的系列节目，或者我们在爱尔兰制作的关于泰坦尼克号的节目。然而，区别在于，记得泰坦尼克号系列、泰坦尼克号戏剧的人，让它如此引人入胜的是，它在某些方面以慢动作展开。这是一个缓慢的穿刺，不是吗？
Yeah. It takes two hours for Titanic to sink. but this is less than 20 minutes of just abjects kind of desperate, urgent panic. There's no kind of women and children first stuff this time? I think it's much too chaotic. Everyone just kind of plowing off to get into life base. Well, we'll come to the women and children first issue because there's some very, very gallant behaviour. I mean, there's no doubt about that.
是的。泰坦尼克号沉没花了两个小时。但这不到20分钟，只是一种绝对绝望、紧急的恐慌。这次没有所谓的妇女和儿童优先吗？我认为太混乱了。每个人都只是为了进入救生艇而冲过去。好吧，我们会谈到妇女和儿童优先的问题，因为有一些非常非常勇敢的行为。我的意思是，毫无疑问。
But there isn't the sort of ordered dance that you get on the Titanic, you know, the sort of the elaborate procedures. Because there's no band playing on the deck. No, no ban playing on the deck. Now, the other big difference, I guess, between Lusitania and Titanic, which affects your women and children first issue, is the Lusitania does have enough lifeboats. So the Lusitania has 48 lifeboats, and that is enough for all the 1,960 people on the ship. The problem is that the ship is now tilting so much, it's listing to Stalbards so badly
但没有你在泰坦尼克号上看到的那种有序的舞蹈，你知道，那种复杂的程序。因为甲板上没有乐队在演奏。不，甲板上没有乐队在演奏。现在，我想卢西塔尼亚号和泰坦尼克号之间的另一个巨大区别，影响了你的妇女和儿童优先问题，是卢西塔尼亚号确实有足够的救生艇。所以卢西塔尼亚号有48艘救生艇，这足以容纳船上的1960人。问题是船现在倾斜得太厉害了，它向右舷倾斜得太严重了
that you basically can't use the boats on that side. Because they're starting to sink into the water. Well, they've swung out wildly. They're on ropes. They've swung out from the ship. And the other thing is, because you're tilted, life bets on the other side, to get them clear of the ship is going to be really, really difficult. Because if you drop them, they'll kind of bump into the... Benponts of the, yeah, inside of the ship.
以至于你基本上不能使用那一侧的船。因为它们开始沉入水中。好吧，它们已经疯狂地摇摆出去了。它们挂在绳子上。它们已经从船上摇摆出去了。另一件事是，因为你倾斜了，另一侧的救生艇，要让它们远离船只将非常非常困难。因为如果你放下它们，它们会撞到……船的内侧。
So it's a very, very chaotic scene and a scene of sort of desperate panic. They are lowering lifeboats, but they're overturning while they're being lowered. There are stories of lifeboats overturning and tipping the people into the sea or lifeboats being launched and then tipping over straight away and passengers jumping into the lifeboats from above and all of this kind of thing. So actually, of those 48 lifeboats, only six of them were lowered successfully. And many of them at that point were massively overcrowded with people. And one of them actually overturned as soon as it landed in the water. And everybody fell out. The lifebed then was turned over again by a wave, and everybody started clambering back onto it again.
所以这是一个非常非常混乱的场景，一个绝望恐慌的场景。他们正在放下救生艇，但它们在放下时翻转了。有关于救生艇翻转并将人们倾倒进海里的故事，或者救生艇被放下然后立即翻转，乘客从上面跳进救生艇，所有这类事情。所以实际上，在那48艘救生艇中，只有6艘被成功放下。而且在那一点上，许多救生艇严重超载。其中一艘在落入水中时立即翻转了。每个人都掉了出来。救生艇随后被海浪再次翻转，每个人又开始爬回上面。
This only lasts for a few minutes, all this kind of stuff, because just 18 minutes after it was hit by the torpedo, the Lusitania begins to plunge down towards the seabed. And it is the most terrifying spectacle, as with the Titanic. So as it sinks, the funnels, the grey-painted funnels, they create whirlpools as they go down. And these whirlpools suck in some of the people who are swimming for the... their lives. Captain Turner, Bowler Bill, is on the deck. He's near the bridge and he's holding the ship's logbook. He's behaving as a captain should, frankly. But he has swept off the deck by a wave and he's swept into the sea. He manages to swim towards a chair that's floating in the water
所有这些只持续了几分钟，因为在被鱼雷击中仅18分钟后，卢西塔尼亚号开始向海床坠落。这是最可怕的景象，就像泰坦尼克号一样。所以当它沉没时，烟囱，灰色的烟囱，在它们下沉时产生了漩涡。这些漩涡吸入了一些为生命而游泳的人。特纳船长，“圆顶礼帽比尔”，在甲板上。他在桥楼附近，手里拿着船的航海日志。坦率地说，他的行为像个船长。但他被海浪从甲板上扫走，被扫进了海里。他设法游向一把漂浮在水中的椅子
and he clings onto this chair, basically clings onto it for three hours. Does he keep the logbook? I think he loses the logbook. I don't know, actually. Surely it would be sodden. Captain Smith would have kept it. He would, absolutely. Well, surely Captain Smith would Isn't it the case that Captain Smith was seen some years later after the Titanic in a New York bar? Yes. Playing the piano, no? Yes.
他紧紧抓住这把椅子，基本上紧紧抓住了三个小时。他保留了航海日志吗？我想他弄丢了航海日志。实际上我不知道。肯定会被浸透的。史密斯船长会保留它的。他会，绝对。好吧，史密斯船长肯定会……难道不是说史密斯船长在泰坦尼克号几年后在纽约的一家酒吧里被看到吗？是的。弹钢琴，不是吗？是的。
Does he not playing the piano? I think he was singing. See shanties. It's like that bloke in COVID who gave up his job as a postman. The thick jersey. Now as with the Titanic, there are some terrible stories about the people in the lifeboats. And here is just one of them,
他不是在弹钢琴吗？我想他在唱歌。唱海员号子。就像COVID期间那个放弃邮递员工作的人。厚毛衣。现在，就像泰坦尼克号一样，有一些关于救生艇上人们的可怕故事。这里只是其中之一，
because we can't go through all of them as we did with Titanic. It's very got one episode. So there was a young Canadian woman called Charlotte Pie and she was traveling with her 18. month-month-old daughter Marjorie. They were helped into a lifeboat by a man who gave them his life belt. As the Lusitania sank, it toppled almost on top of their lifeboat. And meanwhile, loads of more people were jumping into their lifeboat. And in the chaos, their lifeboat tipped over. And both Charlotte and her 18-month-old daughter, Marjorie, were thrown into the water.
因为我们不能像对待泰坦尼克号那样一一讲述。只有一个片段。所以有一个年轻的加拿大妇女叫夏洛特·派，她带着她18个月大的女儿玛乔里旅行。一个男人给了她们他的救生衣，帮助她们进入了救生艇。当卢西塔尼亚号沉没时，它几乎倒在了她们的救生艇上。与此同时，更多的人跳进了她们的救生艇。在混乱中，她们的救生艇翻了。夏洛特和她18个月大的女儿玛乔里都被抛进了水里。
A Marjorie, who's screaming for her mother, is basically ripped away by a wave. Charlotte loses. touch with her. She dies. And Charlotte is then dragged under by the tide. I shall never forget the agony of it, she said later. While I was under the water, I felt my end had come. And she passes out, and she comes to moments later, floating amid the wreckage of the ship, surrounded by bodies.
玛乔里，她为母亲尖叫，基本上被海浪撕裂了。夏洛特失去了与她的联系。她死了。夏洛特随后被潮水拖了下去。我永远不会忘记那种痛苦，她后来回忆说。当我在水下时，我感到我的末日到了。她昏了过去，片刻后醒来，漂浮在船的残骸中，周围都是尸体。
And she said, those that were living were screaming and shouting, wanting to be saved. She clings onto some wreckage, somehow manages to stay afloat, and she's eventually rescued by three men who have gone onto an upturned boat and they sort of drag her up onto this boat. And then they were all eventually rescued by people who came out from the coast of Ireland
她说，活着的人在尖叫和呼喊，想要被救。她紧紧抓住一些残骸，设法保持漂浮，最终被三个爬上一艘翻转船只的男人救起，他们把她拖上了这艘船。然后他们最终都被从爱尔兰海岸出来寻找幸存者的人们救起
on little boats to look for survivors. And is the body of her baby found? Never found. Never found. So that's the end of Marjorie. Very sad. Now as with Titanic, there aren't exact figures for the casualties. There's lots of debate about how many people died. Probably, let's go with the most common, 767 passengers and crew were rescued
在小船上。她的婴儿的尸体找到了吗？从未找到。从未找到。所以这就是玛乔里的结局。非常悲伤。现在就像泰坦尼克号一样，伤亡人数没有确切数字。关于有多少人死亡有很多争论。可能，让我们采用最常见的说法，767名乘客和船员获救
and 1,194 people were killed. So actually, you were better off on the Lusitania than you were on the Titanic. So a four out of 10 survival rate, so a little bit better than Titanic, although better to be a woman on Titanic, I suppose, than just to take your chances of either gender on the Lusitania.
1194人死亡。所以实际上，你在卢西塔尼亚号上比在泰坦尼克号上生存几率更好。所以是十分之四的生存率，比泰坦尼克号稍微好一点，尽管我想在泰坦尼克号上做个女人比在卢西塔尼亚号上不分性别地碰运气要好。
But you mentioned that women and children first. The Titanic, by and large, children survive. in this case 94 of the dead were children and even more scandalously 128 of the dead were American and most of the bodies were never recovered and among the dead there are you go through the list I mean there are people who were prominent at the time and are now forgotten so sort of novelists and art collectors and engineers and whatnot and what about the the American millionaire what's in Vanderbilt van derbilt where he is by far the most famous casualty. We love a millionaire behaving well, a doomed millionaire behaving gallantly,
但你提到了妇女和儿童优先。泰坦尼克号，总的来说，儿童幸存了。在这种情况下，死者中有94名是儿童，更令人愤慨的是，死者中有128名是美国人，大多数尸体从未被找回。在死者中，你去看看名单，我的意思是，有当时显赫但现在已被遗忘的人，比如小说家、艺术收藏家和工程师等等。那么那位美国百万富翁呢？范德比尔特，他是迄今为止最著名的伤亡者。我们喜欢表现良好的百万富翁，一个表现英勇的注定失败的百万富翁，
and he absolutely did behave gallantly. Yeah, because we had just recently been doing a series of shows in Ireland, haven't we, about Titanic. And we pondered whether Jeff Bezos or Elon Musk would behave as well as American plutocrats did back in the 1910s. An open question, I think. Yeah, I'm interested to know what the listeners think. So Vanderbilt behaved splendidly. He was very impressive. Lots of passengers said they saw him talking to a young mother carrying a baby and he's saying to her, I will find you an extra life jacket. And he couldn't find her an extra life jacket. So he took his own life jacket off and he gave it to this woman. And this woman actually may have been the woman we just described. Charlotte Pie. There are different descriptions. So it's not entirely clear,
他绝对表现得英勇。是的，因为我们最近一直在爱尔兰做一系列节目，不是吗，关于泰坦尼克号。我们思考了杰夫·贝佐斯或埃隆·马斯克是否会像1910年代的美国财阀那样表现得好。我认为这是一个悬而未决的问题。是的，我很想知道听众们怎么想。所以范德比尔特表现得非常出色。他令人印象深刻。许多乘客说他们看到他和一个带着婴儿的年轻母亲交谈，他对她说，我会为你找一件额外的救生衣。但他没能为她找到额外的救生衣。所以他脱下自己的救生衣，给了这个女人。这个女人实际上可能就是我们刚才描述的那个女人。夏洛特·派。有不同的描述。所以并不完全清楚，
but it may well have been her. And the ship's barber who escaped said later that he saw Vanderbilt and I quote, trying to put life jackets on women and children, plural. The ship was going down fast. I never saw Vanderbilt after that. All I saw in the water was children everywhere. Good on him. Yeah, good on him. And then the other story that really sticks in my mind,
但很可能是她。后来逃生的船上理发师说，他看到范德比尔特，引用，试图给妇女和儿童（复数）穿上救生衣。船沉得很快。在那之后我再也没见过范德比尔特。我在水里看到的只有到处都是孩子。他做得好。是的，他做得好。然后另一个真正留在脑海里的故事，
the longest lived person to survive the Lusitania was an American girl called Audrey Pearl. I already mentioned the Pearl family very briefly in the first half. Oh, with the nanny, the nervous, and this nanny. So Audrey, they were an American family, and Audrey was three months old, when she got on the Lusitania. She was travelling with her parents
卢西塔尼亚号幸存者中最长寿的人是一个叫奥黛丽·珀尔的美国女孩。我在上半部分非常简短地提到了珀尔一家。哦，和那个保姆，那个紧张的，这个保姆。所以奥黛丽，他们是一个美国家庭，奥黛丽上卢西塔尼亚号时才三个月大。她和她的父母一起旅行
and her older siblings. And she was with her brother, Stuart, who was five, and they were in their cabin, and they were being fed by this English nanny, Alice Lines. And Alice Lines was 17. Right.
和她年长的兄弟姐妹。她和她五岁的哥哥斯图尔特在一起，他们在船舱里，由这个英国保姆爱丽丝·莱恩斯喂养。爱丽丝·莱恩斯17岁。对。
She came from Suffolk. And she was feeding Audrey. She'd taken them basically downstairs when the torpedo struck. And Alice, they don't know where the rest of the family are, but Alice, this nanny, showing,
她来自萨福克郡。当时她正在喂奥黛丽。鱼雷击中船时，她基本上刚把孩子们带到楼下。而爱丽丝，虽然他们不知道家里其他人都在哪儿，但爱丽丝，这位保姆，表现出了极大的勇气，她设法把孩子们带到楼上并送进了一艘救生艇。
tremendous courage, she manages to get the children upstairs and into a lifeboat. And there, unbelievably, or perhaps very believably, a Frenchman used the opportunity of being a lifeboat to try to crack onto her. So this Frenchman said to her, that's very French behavior. He whispers in her ear. He says, you have perhaps lost your husbands. Do not worry, I am wealthy. I will look after you. I don't think she took him up on that offer. Anyway, Alice and the two children, Stuart and Audrey, survived. And they were eventually, I'm happy to say, reunited with Mr. and Mrs. Pearl, who had also survived and been picked up by steamers from the shore.
在那里，令人难以置信，或者也许非常可信的是，一个法国人利用在救生艇上的机会试图搭讪她。所以这个法国人对她说，这真是非常法国式的行为。他在她耳边低语。他说，你可能失去了丈夫。别担心，我很富有。我会照顾你的。我想她并没有接受他的提议。总之，爱丽丝和两个孩子，斯图尔特和奥黛丽，幸存了下来。我很高兴地说，他们最终与珀尔夫妇团聚了，珀尔夫妇也幸存了下来，并被岸上的轮船救起。
And Alice Lines, the nanny, died aged 100 in 1997. Oh, my God. And if you think that's mind-blowing, Audrey, the baby, lived to the age of 95 and died in 2011. God, that's incredible. I mean, that really blows your kind, that kind of messes with your sense of kind of historical periodization. Yeah. Yeah. There's somebody who basically was on the Lusitania lived to see the David Cameron Cameron Premier Show. Well, how lucky for her. She wouldn't have wanted to miss that. She'd have been able to read, which of your books was most recently published then?
保姆爱丽丝·莱恩斯于1997年去世，享年100岁。天哪。如果你觉得这很令人震惊，那么那个婴儿奥黛丽活到了95岁，于2011年去世。天哪，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，这真的让你大开眼界，那种感觉打乱了你对历史分期的认知。是的。是的。有一个人基本上在卢西塔尼亚号上，却活到了看到戴维·卡梅伦担任首相。好吧，她真幸运。她肯定不想错过那个。她应该能读到你最近出版的那本书了，是哪一本？
I think Millennium. Millennium. She'd have been able to read Millennium and that killed her. Well, maybe it was whatever, seasons in the sun. State of emergency. The Heath years. I mean, she was so depressed by that that she just thought, I can't live on and finish it. I need, give me more, Tony Ben. Give me more. Right. Now, we should just mention some of the conspiracy theories about the, I've been waiting for this.
我想是《千年》。《千年》。她应该能读到《千年》，然后那本书把她看死了。好吧，也许是别的什么，比如《阳光下的季节》、《紧急状态》、《希思岁月》。我的意思是，她对此感到非常沮丧，以至于她只是想，我无法活下去并读完它。我需要，给我更多，托尼·本。给我更多。好了。现在，我们应该提一下关于这件事的一些阴谋论，我一直在等这个。
So the conspiracy theory is that it's actually loaded with explosives. Well, there's multiple conspiracy theories, Tom. And we actually don't have time for all of them. So number one is, yes, it was carrying like secret explosives. It was hit by the German torpedo. What destroyed the ship was the second explosion, which was the secret explosives. And so it's not really the German's fault at all. It's the British fault.
所以阴谋论是它实际上装满了炸药。好吧，汤姆，有很多阴谋论。我们实际上没有时间讲完所有这些。所以第一点是，是的，它携带了秘密炸药。它被德国鱼雷击中。摧毁这艘船的是第二次爆炸，也就是那些秘密炸药。所以这根本不是德国人的错。这是英国人的错。
But people don't rate that. Historians don't rate that. And generally, the theme that runs through a lot of these conspiracy theories is that it's obscurely Britain's fault. So they're very popular among sort of American isolationists who would now probably be of quite a mager tendency. I mean, in a way, it reflects well on the reputation of the British spy agencies for kind of cunning.
但人们并不买账。历史学家不买账。总的来说，贯穿许多这些阴谋论的主题是，这模糊地归咎于英国。所以它们在美国孤立主义者中非常受欢迎，这些人现在可能倾向于“让美国再次伟大”（MAGA）。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这反映了英国间谍机构在狡诈方面的声誉。
Yes. That's how I see it. Now, then we come to the second conspiracy theory. and this is by far the one that has the most traction in that particular community. This is that basically the British wanted the Lusitania to be sunk. And then actually it's really the fault
是的。我也是这么看的。那么，我们来说说第二个阴谋论。这是目前为止在那个特定群体中最有影响力的一个。这就是基本上英国人希望卢西塔尼亚号被击沉。实际上这真的是第一海军大臣温斯顿·丘吉尔的错。
of the First Lord of the Admiralty, Winston Churchill. What is it about American isolationists and Churchill? They just think he's a bad person. I mean, we know what it is. He's the real villain in the war, right? He is the real villain in every war. And they think Churchill is the real villain of this story. I mean, there is a letter or something that Churchill writes at the beginning of 1915.
美国孤立主义者和丘吉尔之间到底是怎么回事？他们只是认为他是个坏人。我的意思是，我们知道是怎么回事。他是战争中真正的恶棍，对吧？他是每一场战争中真正的恶棍。他们认为丘吉尔是这个故事中真正的恶棍。我的意思是，有一封信或类似的东西，是丘吉尔在1915年初写的。
Well, listen, he loves a sunk ship, doesn't he? Yeah. Because he was all over the sinking of the Titanic and said how proud it makes him feel to be British. He wrote a letter at some point to somebody, and I cannot remember the exact details, which probably shows that I'm part of the conspiracy. He wrote a letter to somebody in the British government, and he said it would be absolutely wonderful if the German sank a passenger liner because that would look great. And, you know, I think this would be brilliant.
好吧，听着，他喜欢沉船，不是吗？是的。因为他当时对泰坦尼克号的沉没非常关注，并说这让他感到身为英国人是多么自豪。他在某个时候给某人写了一封信，我不记得确切的细节了，这可能表明我是阴谋的一部分。他给英国政府的某个人写了一封信，他说如果德国人击沉一艘客轮那将是绝对美妙的，因为那看起来会很棒。而且，你知道，我认为这会很棒。
It would bring the Americans into the war. it's mad that both the Germans and the British are saying it would be great if it got sunk. So the claim is that basically Churchill deliberately put the Lusitania in harm's way, that he could have diverted it, he could have provided an escort for it, because he wanted a sinking to get the Americans into the war. And this is actually, this is clearly complete rubbish. So basically, it would have been mad to give the Lusitania an escort because the Lusitania was so fast.
这会把美国人拉入战争。德国人和英国人都说如果它被击沉会很棒，这太疯狂了。所以这种说法是，基本上丘吉尔故意把卢西塔尼亚号置于危险之中，他本可以改变航线，他本可以为它提供护航，因为他想要一次沉船事件来让美国人加入战争。这实际上，这显然完全是胡说八道。所以基本上，给卢西塔尼亚号提供护航是疯狂的，因为卢西塔尼亚号太快了。
It would be so fast, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah, it would be better for the Lusitania to just rush across. I mean, if you've won the Lusitania, blue ribbon. There's no way that anyone can keep up with you. No. And also the thing about the warnings, as I've already described, they were getting loads of warnings the whole time. I mean, Captain Turner, Bowler Bill, he basically said, I got so many warnings, you know, I was just overwhelmed with warnings. Yeah. I mean, what do you expect me to do? I was just sailing the right
它太快了，不是吗？是的。是的，让卢西塔尼亚号直接冲过去会更好。我的意思是，如果你赢得了卢西塔尼亚号，蓝丝带奖。没有人能跟上你。不。还有关于警告的事情，正如我已经描述的那样，他们一直收到大量的警告。我的意思是，特纳船长，“保龄球比尔”，他基本上说，我收到了太多的警告，你知道，我被警告淹没了。是的。我的意思是，你指望我做什么？我只是在走正确的航线。
way. They've got tons of warnings, and unfortunately, it was sunk by you by end of story. So I don't really believe in the conspiracy theorist to cut a long story short. I mean, Occam's Razor, the simplest explanation is slightly, always the likeliest. But actually the single, but actually the Sinking the ship is only the beginning of the story. Our producers will be delighted to hear that when they look at the clock. Another three pages worth of the story to go. The real story is the publicity war, the propaganda war that follows the sinking. Because obviously this is a big deal.
他们收到了大量的警告，不幸的是，它被击沉了，故事结束。所以我真的不相信阴谋论者，长话短说。我的意思是，奥卡姆剃刀定律，最简单的解释通常总是最可能的。但实际上，击沉这艘船只是故事的开始。我们的制片人听到我们看时间时会很高兴的。还有三页的故事要讲。真正的故事是随后的宣传战，舆论战。因为显然这是一件大事。
A thousand people have been killed. And in terms of sort of naval disasters, it's really comparable only to the Titanic. I mean, up to the point that James Cameron did his film, you know, James Cameron film obviously made the Titanic. colossal, colossal, pop cultural phenomenon. But up to that point, the Lusitania and the Titanic, where I would say probably neck and neck in terms of publicity. Yeah, Lusitania was massive.
一千人丧生。就海军灾难而言，它真的只能与泰坦尼克号相提并论。我的意思是，在詹姆斯·卡梅隆拍电影之前，你知道，詹姆斯·卡梅隆的电影显然让泰坦尼克号成为了巨大的、巨大的流行文化现象。但在那之前，卢西塔尼亚号和泰坦尼克号，我会说在宣传方面可能是不相上下的。是的，卢西塔尼亚号非常轰动。
Lusitia is massive. If you read, for example, Agatha Christie's thrillers, so there's one called, it's a Tommy and Tupin's Thrill. I think it's the secret adversary. The Lusitania runs right through this book. But Titanic has the kind of metaphorical heft that I think the Lusitania doesn't. I think Lusitania is massive. And also Lusitania really matters in terms of the war.
卢西塔尼亚号非常轰动。如果你读，例如，阿加莎·克里斯蒂的惊悚小说，有一本叫《秘密对手》，它是汤米和塔彭丝系列。卢西塔尼亚号贯穿了整本书。但泰坦尼克号有一种我认为卢西塔尼亚号所没有的隐喻分量。我认为卢西塔尼亚号非常轰动。而且卢西塔尼亚号在战争方面确实很重要。
So in Germany, what's the response? Because I mean, I imagine among the iceberg community, there was no great rejoicing at the sinking of Titanic. No, but what about the Germans? Are they cocker hoop? The Germans, it may surprise some listeners, the Germans don't feel bad about this at all. They think we've done our job and we've done it brilliantly. So the official line in Berlin is, look, the Lusitania, you know, the British government put money into building it because they wanted to use it as an auxiliary ship. It could have been fitted with guns. It's carrying war material in the cargo. Most German newspapers say, well done for sinking it. So the Frankfurters Zaitung calls it an extraordinary success.
那么在德国，反应是什么？因为我的意思是，我想在冰山社区中，对泰坦尼克号的沉没并没有什么大的欢庆。不，但德国人呢？他们欣喜若狂吗？德国人，这可能会让一些听众感到惊讶，德国人对此一点也不感到难过。他们认为我们完成了我们的工作，而且完成得非常出色。所以柏林的官方立场是，看，卢西塔尼亚号，你知道，英国政府投入资金建造它，因为他们想把它用作辅助舰。它本可以安装火炮。它在货物中携带战争物资。大多数德国报纸说，击沉它干得好。所以《法兰克福日报》称其为一次非凡的成功。
A Catholic Centre Party newspaper says, you know, the British are behaving very badly at sea. This is our reprisals, our refrains. Because they're blockading us. Yeah. With joyful pride, we contemplate this latest deed of our Navy. The English wished to abandon the German people's death by starvation, but we are more humane. We simply sank an English ship with passengers who entered the war zone at their own risk. I mean, it's not untrue, actually.
一份天主教中央党报纸说，你知道，英国人在海上表现得非常糟糕。这是我们的报复，我们的回击。因为他们在封锁我们。是的。我们怀着喜悦的自豪感注视着我们海军的这一最新壮举。英国人希望让德国人民死于饥饿，但我们更人道。我们只是击沉了一艘英国船，船上的乘客是自担风险进入战区的。我的意思是，这其实并非不真实。
Yeah, but it's not wise in the context of winning global opinion for your policies. It's not wise. Well, what's definitely not wise is that they produce propaganda postcards showing the sinking. They produce medals, unofficial medals, making fun of Kuhnard. And some of these medals show there's lucidaneous sinking. and they show the Lusitania bristling with guns because they want people to perceive the Lusitania as a military target. I mean, one of these medals has a skeleton
是的，但在赢得全球舆论支持你的政策的背景下，这并不明智。这不明智。好吧，绝对不明智的是，他们制作了展示沉船的宣传明信片。他们制作了奖章，非官方的奖章，嘲笑库纳德航运公司。其中一些奖章显示卢西塔尼亚号正在沉没，并且它们显示卢西塔尼亚号上布满了火炮，因为他们想让人们把卢西塔尼亚号视为军事目标。我的意思是，其中一枚奖章上有一个骷髅在卖库纳德的船票，座右铭是“生意至上”。换句话说，库纳德牺牲了他们自己乘客的生命，只是为了赚钱。这就是那种说法。现在，在英国，当然，反应非常不同。绝大多数受害者是英国人或加拿大人。人们认为这是一场无法言喻的战争罪行。
selling CUNARD tickets, and the motto is business above all. In other words, Cunard sacrificed the lives of their own passengers just so they could make money. That's the claim. Now, in Britain, of course, the reaction is very different. The vast majority of the victims are British or Canadian. People see it as an unspeakable war crime.
甚至比比利时的暴行更甚，我认为。这是在英国公众心中确立德国野蛮主义、匈奴人罪行观念的时刻。我假设人们不知道卢西塔尼亚号携带弹药的可能性，不，不是可能性，而是事实。不，因为根据《王国防御法》，实际上实行了审查制度，所以报纸上根本没有提到这艘船实际上携带了所有这些弹药。
even more, I think, than the atrocities in Belgium. This is the moment that establishes the idea in the British public mind of German barbarism, of the crimes of the Han. I assume that there's no awareness of the possibility that, well, not possibility, the fact that the Lusitania is carrying ammunition. No, because under the defence of the Realm Act, there is effectively censorship in force, and so there was no mention in the newspapers that actually the ship is
所以对英国人来说，这看起来就像德国人无缘无故地击沉了一艘客轮。是的。因为他们是残忍的人。所有这些都市传说都在英国滋生。例如，在1910年代的英国，人们普遍认为，几乎毫无疑问，德国学童被放了一天假来庆祝卢西塔尼亚号的沉没。这根本不是真的，但它变得根深蒂固。或者人们得到了我刚才谈到的那些奖章，他们说他们弄到了它们的副本。他们说，这些实际上是德国政府铸造的。这是一个官方的东西。这是发给孩子们的。这不是真的。这些是非官方的、私下制作的战争纪念品。但英国海军情报局成立了一个卢西塔尼亚纪念奖章委员会，基本上制作了这枚奖章的副本。然后他们卖出了25万枚，为英国红十字会筹集资金。我的意思是，这是一种疯狂的事情，但是，你知道，它在传播德国野蛮主义的观念方面非常有效。还有大量的海报和明信片展示了，最著名的一张，是一个少女，她举着一把剑。背景中，卢西塔尼亚号正在沉没。有人在溺水。标题写着，“拿起正义之剑”。换句话说，为所有在卢西塔尼亚号上丧生的妇女和儿童复仇。
carrying all of this ammunition. So to the British, it just seems that the Germans have sunk a liner for the hell of it. Yeah. Because they're cruel people. And all of these urban myths bred in Britain. So, for example, it was widely believed, I think almost unquestioned in Britain in the 1910s, that German school children have been given the day off school to celebrate the sinking of the Lusitania. This was just not true, but it became absolutely embedded. Or people get those medals that I was talking about and they say they get hold of, of copies of them. And they say, well, these were actually struck by the German government. This is an
但我认为在英国，这符合公众舆论已经有的想法。是的。但美国呢？因为那是德国人和英国人争夺的关键市场。正如我所说，大约128名美国人在卢西塔尼亚号上丧生。这是一个巨大的故事。所以我们已经提到了西奥多·罗斯福。
official thing. This was given out to children. And this is not true. These were unofficial, privately produced kind of war merch. But naval intelligence in Britain got, they set up a lucetania souvenir medal committee, which basically produced copies of this medal. And then they sold a quarter of a million of them to raise money for the Red Cross in Britain. I mean, that's a kind of mad thing, but, you know, it's hugely effective in spreading the idea of German barbarism. And there were loads of posters and postcards showing kind of, the most famous one, it's a maiden, she's holding up a sword. And in the background, the Lusitania is sinking. And there are people drowning. And the caption says, take up the sword of justice. In other words, avenge all the women and children.
前总统西奥多·罗斯福说，来吧，让我们现在投入这场战争。我们应该参与进来。德国人是海盗，所有这些东西。违禁品问题确实在那里被报道了，武器问题。但美国当局说这是完全合理的。我们一直都在船上运送小型武器弹药。这不是德国人的借口。
who were killed on the Lusitania. But I suppose in Britain, this is going with the grain of what public opinion already thinks. Yes. But what about America? Because that's the crucial kind of market for the Germans and the British to compete over. So as I said, about 128 Americans died on the Lusitania. And it is a colossal story. So we already mentioned Theodore Roosevelt.
你知道，这真的不是战争物资。这是给私人公民的，等等等等。那是真的吗？我认为这在很大程度上是牵强附会。我认为如果你是德国人，你会说，得了吧。不能说这是为了射杀松鸡什么的。是的，完全正确。这是为了射杀松鼠。
Theodore Roosevelt, the former president, says, come on, let's get stuck into this war now. We should get involved. the Germans are pirates, all of this kind of thing. The contraband issue does get reported there, the arms issue. But the United States authorities say it's completely reasonable. We've always been sending small arms cartridges on ships. This is not an excuse for the Germans.
那雷管呢？你要去炸松鼠和松鸡吗？当然。那威尔逊总统呢？威尔逊总统起初竭尽全力。他有点像吉米·卡特。所以沉船三天后，他在费城发表了演讲，他正在对刚刚成为美国公民的人说话。
You know, it's not really war material. It's for private citizens, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Is that true? I think it's massively stretching a point. I think if you were German, you would say, come on. Couldn't say it's for shooting grouse or something. Yeah, exactly. It's for shooting squirrels.
他说，我们很特别。你知道，美国必须是一个特别的榜样，和平的榜样，因为和平是世界的治愈和提升力量，而冲突不是。然后是这一句，“一个人有‘太骄傲而不能打仗’这回事。一个国家有‘太正确而不需要通过武力说服他人它是正确的’这回事。”我的意思是，这真是太美国式的说法了。
What about the percussion fuses? Are you going to be blowing up squirrels and grouse? Sure. What about President Wilson, though? President Wilson goes out of his way at first. He does a bit of a Jimmy Carter. So three days after the sinking, he gives a speech in Philadelphia, and he's talking to people who've just become American citizens.
现在不是这样了。不，很难想象威尔逊的现代继任者会那样说，不是吗？但他因为这个被大规模嘲笑，威尔逊。我的意思是，人们说，真是个十足的懦夫。真是个软蛋。所以一家英国报纸制作了一幅漫画，标题是“失败的哥伦比亚”，它展示了德皇字面上在对一个傲慢但最终软弱的伍德罗·威尔逊嗤之以鼻。标题是，“太骄傲而不能打仗，太正确而不能纠正错误，太聪明而不能与智慧同行，太强大而不能变得强硬。”
And he says, we're special. You know, America must be a special example, the example of peace, because peace is the healing and elevating influence of the world, and strife is not. And then this line, there is such a thing as a man being too proud to fight. There is such a thing as a nation being so right that it does not need to convince others by force that it is right. I mean, that's such an American thing to say.
尖刻。所以美国政府内部随后发生了巨大的争论，它基本上以国务卿威廉·詹宁斯·布莱恩的辞职而告终，已经提到了这种激进的草原民粹主义者。他最终实际上辞职了。有一个大争论，我们要向德国人投诉吗？威尔逊同意他会，他最终被说服他会投诉。他给德国人发了一系列照会。所以布莱恩辞职了，因为他认为这太挑衅了。他认为这太挑衅了。他认为，甚至不要，我的意思是，我认为这对布莱恩来说相当疯狂。把弹药问题放在一边。如果你的128名公民被U型潜艇击沉，而你不投诉，
Not at the moment. No, it's hard to imagine Wilson's present-day successor saying that, isn't it? But he is massively mocked for this, Wilson. I mean, people say, what an absolute wimp. What a weed. So one British newspaper produced a cartoon entitled, fail Columbia, and it shows the Kaiser literally kind of thumbing his nose as a sort of haughty, but ultimately wimpish Woodrow Wilson. And the caption, too proud to fight, too right to right
你什么时候才会投诉？但他是个孤立主义者，不是吗？所以他永远不会投诉。是的。威尔逊确实投诉了。他给德国人发了，不完全是最后通牒，但他基本上说，你知道，这次沉船是完全不合理的。
a wrong, too wise to walk with wisdom, too mighty to be strong. Stinging. So there's then a huge argument within the US administration, and it basically ends with the Secretary of State, William Jennings Brian, already mentioned this kind of radical prairie populist. He ends up actually resigning. There's a big argument, are we going to complain to the Germans? Wilson agrees that he will find, he finally is persuaded that he will complain. He sends the Germans a series of notes. And so Brian resigns because he thinks this is too provocative. He thinks it's too provocative. He thinks, don't even, I mean, I think this is pretty bonkers from Brian. Put the ammunition issue on one side. If 128 of your citizens are sunk by a U-boat and you don't complain,
这完全是你们的错。不要再这样做了。如果你继续击沉我们的船只，那将等同于战争。但威尔逊此时并没有卷入战争。实际上，德国人让他变得容易，因为在整个这一集里，
when would you complain? But he's an isolationist, isn't he? So he would never complain. Yeah. Wilson does complain. He sends the Germans, not quite an ultimatum, but he basically says, you know, the sinking was totally unjustified.
记住，他们一直在争论他们是否在做正确的事情。在卢西塔尼亚号沉没后，总理特奥巴登·冯·贝特曼-霍尔维格和陆军参谋长埃里希·冯·法尔肯海恩，以及德皇，对海军说，不要再这样做了。我们不。我们不能冒这个险。不值得。一点也不值得。
It was totally your fault. Don't do this again. If you keep sinking our ships, that will be tantamount to war. But what Wilson doesn't do is get involved in the war at this point. And actually, the Germans make this easy for him, because all through this episode,
这场运动又持续了几周。他们确实又击沉了一艘客轮，阿拉伯号。你看，那从来没被谈论过，是吗？不。那次沉船中有44人死亡。那是从利物浦开往纽约的。同样，它是在爱尔兰海岸外。所以为什么那不是一件大事？
remember, they have been arguing themselves about whether they're doing the right thing. And after the sinking of the Lusitania, the Chancellor, Tehbal-Betman-Holweg, and the army chief, Eric von Falkenheim, and indeed the Kaiser, say to the Navy, do not do this again. We do not. We cannot run the risk. Not worth it. Not worth it at all.
嗯，没那么多人。所以它完全被卢西塔尼亚号掩盖了。是的，好吧。实际的沉没有点模糊。不完全清楚德国人是有意还是无意，他们是否意识到那是一艘客轮。所以我认为在这种情况下，他们的罪责稍微小一点。但无论如何，长话短说，
The campaign continues for a few more weeks. They do actually sink one more liner, the Arabic. You see, that's never talked about, is it? No. 44 people died on that sinking. That was heading from Liverpool to New York. Again, it was off the coast of Ireland. So why is that not a big deal?
德皇随后说，受够了无限制的潜艇战。1915年9月18日，所有U型潜艇都被从大西洋和英吉利海峡召回。虽然这场运动在北海继续，但德国人随后说，好吧，我们将遵循旧的巡洋舰规则，我们将停止在没有警告的情况下击沉船只。到1915年底，这就是形势。英国人仍然对德国实施海军封锁。实际上从长远来看，虽然这并没有被真正谈论，人们通常不会想到第一次世界大战的海上战争。这是德国输掉第一次世界大战的重大原因之一。
Well, not that many people. So it's completely eclipsed by the Lusitania. Yeah, okay. The actual sinking was a little bit murky. It's not entirely clear whether the Germans did it deliberately or not, where they didn't realize it was a liner. So I think in this case, they're a little bit less culpable. But anyway, to cut a long story short,
对德国的挤压。以及物资等等。完全正确。我的意思是，他们喝着，你知道，用，我不知道，老鼠药做的咖啡。是的，完全正确。而且只吃芜菁什么的。我的意思是，德国人过得很惨。
the Kaiser then said, enough of the unrestricted suburb. marine warfare. And on the 18th of September 1915, all U-boats were recalled from the Atlantic and from the English Channel. And although the campaign continued in the North Sea, the Germans then said, well, we'll follow the old cruiser rules, will stop sinking ships without warning. By the end of 1915, this was the position. The British has still got their naval blockade of Germany. And actually in the long run, although it's not really talked about, It's not, people don't often think about the First World War at sea. This is one of the big reasons that Germany lost the First World War.
德国的潜艇运动失败了。他们甚至没有接近切断英国的贸易联系。但美国人此时仍然没有参与。事实上，伍德罗·威尔逊仍然决心置身事外，1916年，他以“他让我们远离战争”为口号竞选连任。但卢西塔尼亚号沉没后，情况确实发生了变化。它给美国公众舆论留下了深刻的印象，
The squeeze on Germany. And on supplies and everything. Exactly. I mean, the fact they're drinking, you know, coffee made of, I don't know. Rat poison. Yeah, exactly. And eating nothing but turnips or whatever. I mean, they're having a terrible time, the Germans.
包括伍德罗·威尔逊身边的人。所以威廉·詹宁斯·布莱恩的国务卿继任者，是一个叫罗伯特·兰辛的人。兰辛后来在回忆录中写道，卢西塔尼亚号的沉没让我确信，我们最终会成为英国的盟友。所以有一种感觉，这只是时间问题。当1917年，在极度绝望中，
The German submarine campaign has failed. They've not come remotely close to cutting Britain's trade links. But the Americans at this point are still not involved. Indeed, Woodrow Wilson is still determined to stay out, and in 1916, he runs for re-election on the slogan, he kept us out of war. But something definitely changed after the Sinky of the Lusitania. It made a massive impression on American public opinion,
德国重启了潜艇运动，这把美国人拖入了战争，然后美国招募运动的一个核心要素，在所有海报、所有招募明信片和所有这些中发挥作用的，就是卢西塔尼亚号。但我猜那是我们操之过急了，汤姆，因为我们还在1915年。下次我们将讨论另一个成为宣传战关键武器的故事，一个在当时和卢西塔尼亚号沉没一样臭名昭著的故事。
including among people close to Woodrow Wilson. So William Jennings is Brian's replacement as Secretary of State, as a guy called Robert Lansing. And Lansing wrote in his memoirs, afterwards, that the sinking of the Lusitania left me with a conviction that we would ultimately become the ally of Britain. So there's a sense that it's only a matter of time. And when, in absolute desperation in 1917,
这就是英国护士伊迪丝·卡维尔的故事，她被德国人指控是被占领比利时地下间谍网络的一部分。所以问题是，她是无辜的烈士还是英国间谍？或者两者兼而有之。如果你想找出这些问题的答案，俱乐部成员可以立即收听这一集以及接下来的两集关于加里波利的内容。要加入他们并获得轰动的全套福利，你必须去 TheRestIsHistory.com 注册。但现在，谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听，再见。再见。大家好。我们带着关于“历史的其余部分”节日的另一个绝对巨大的更新回来了。
Germany restarts the submarine campaign, that drags the Americans into the war and then a central element of its recruitment, of the American recruitment campaign, playing a part in all the posters and all the recruitment postcards and all of this is the Lusitania. But I guess that's to get ahead of ourselves, Tom, because we're still in 1915. And next time we'll be talking about another story that became a key weapon in the propaganda war, a story that in its time was just as notorious as the sinking of the Lusitania.
嗯，这太轰动了。所以7月4日和5日，我们将在汉普顿宫。我们有一个周末的精彩讲座、现场音乐、对历史悠久的皇家宫殿收藏的独家访问。是的，多米尼克，最令人兴奋的是，这是我一直推动的事情，我非常期待。我们有中世纪格斗，一项可怕、残酷但又完全令人兴奋的运动。这将是令人难忘的两天。确实如此。
And this is the story of the British nurse Edith Cavill, who was accused by the Germans of being part of an underground spy. network in occupied Belgium. So the question, was she an innocent martyr or a British secret agent? Or possibly both. And if you want to find out the answer to those questions, club members can hear the episode and the following two episodes which are about Gallipoli right away. And to join them and to get the sensational full array of benefits, you have to go to The Rest Is History.com and sign there. But for now, thank you, Dominic. Thank you everyone for listening and goodbye. Bye-bye. Hi, everybody. We are back with another absolutely colossal update about the rest is history festival.
在这些讲座的节日核心，我们还有更多的讲座要加入阵容。所以我将与杰出的都铎历史学家特蕾西·博曼谈论亨利八世六位妻子的秘密。我将与节目的朋友和爱尔兰国宝保罗·劳斯谈论是否存在一个爱尔兰可能仍然是英国一部分的平行宇宙。我们将与卡佳·霍耶谈论魏玛德国，特别是魏玛镇的历史，
Well, it's massive. So on the 4th and 5th of July, we will be at Hampton Court Palace. We have a weekend of brilliant talks, live music, exclusive access to historic Royal Palace's collections. And yes, Dominic, most exciting of all, this is the thing I have been pushing for. and I'm so looking forward to it. We have medieval combat, a terrifying, brutal, yet completely thrilling sport. It is going to be an unforgettable two days. It is indeed.
亚当·史密斯教授将通过三位总统讲述美国的故事。最重要的是，我将与伊恩·希斯洛普一起举办一场关于讽刺历史的特别活动。我将与玛丽·比尔德同台，我们将讨论罗马是多么奇怪、多么陌生、多么与我们不同，或者也许并非如此。我将与海伦·卡斯特谈论伊丽莎白，我将讨论她是否真的是英国最伟大的统治者，或者也许那个头衔仍然应该由埃塞尔斯坦拥有。我将与阿里·安萨里谈论波斯的一切，与丹·杰克逊谈论死亡之坑。我将与节目的朋友威利·达尔林普尔谈论古代印度与希腊和罗马之间的联系。绝对令人难以置信的场景。当然，在这两天里，汤姆和我也会一起在舞台上表演。所以第一天，我们将回答我们所有俱乐部成员的问题。然后为了结束节日，我们将对节目有史以来最好的朋友进行最终排名。
And at the core of the festival of these talks, and we've got some more talks to add to the lineup. So I will be talking to the brilliant Tudor historian Tracy Borman about the secrets of the six wives of Henry VIII. I'll be talking to a friend of the show and Irish National Treasure, Paul Rouse, about whether there is an alternative universe in which islands could have remained part of the United Kingdom. We'll be talking to Katja Hoyer about Weimar, Germany, and in particular, the town of Weimar through history,
所以有很多值得期待的事情。除此之外，整个周末还会发生很多其他事情。所以把它想象成终极的夏季历史聚会。你的门票将让你完全进入探索汉普顿宫这座伟大的都铎宫殿，当然还有皇家网球场。所以那会非常令人兴奋。会有适合国王的食物和饮料，听起来非常诱人。
and Professor Adam Smith will be telling the story of America through three presidents. And on top of all that, I'll be doing a special event with Ian Hizlop about the history of satire. And I will be on stage with Mary Beard and we will be talking about just how strange, just how alien, just how different to us Rome was or maybe it wasn't. I will be talking to Helen Castor about Elizabeth I'll be discussing whether she truly was England's greatest ruler or maybe whether that title should still be claimed by Athelstan. I will be talking to Ali Ansari about all things Persian with Dan Jackson about the pit of death. And I will be talking to a friend of the show, Willie Dalrymple, about the links between ancient India and Greece and Rome. Absolutely incredible scenes. And of course, on both days, Tom and I will be on stage doing a show together as well. So on the first day, we'll be answering all our club members' questions. And then to close the festival, we will do a definitive ranking of the all-time top friends of the show.
我想象着我们俱乐部成员那些非常迷人的人穿着夏装。他们在汉普顿宫的草坪上。他们在愉快的环境中谈论历史，啜饮清爽的金汤力。这可能是史上最文明的节日。我的意思是，这就是我的想象。再次提醒，门票仅限俱乐部成员。如果你不是会员，现在是加入的最佳时机。所以前往 TheRestIsHistory.com 注册并抢购你的门票。
So lots to look forward to. And beyond that, there is so much. else that will be happening across the weekend. So think of it as the ultimate summer history hangout. And your tickets will give you full access to explore the great Tudor Palace of Hampton Court and indeed the Royal Tennis Court. So that would be very exciting. There will be food and drink fit for a king, which sounds very enticing.
当然，还可以获得一系列补充福利。一旦你注册了 TheRestIsHistory.com，你所要做的就是登录会员区，选择节日，一切都非常明显。但你知道吗？有一个转折。如果你这样做，你将参加一个真正令人难以置信的抽奖。那个抽奖，如果你赢了，你和其他三个人，就像《查理和巧克力工厂》里的金奖券，因为你将有机会升级到高级体验，高级体验将为你提供，除其他外，全天免费无限量的食物和饮料。
I picture the very glamorous people that are our club members and their summer garb. They're on the lawn at Hampton Court Palace. They're chatting about history and delightful surroundings, sipping on a refreshing gin and tonic. And it's probably the most civilised festival there's ever been. I mean, that's what I imagine anyway. Just a reminder, the tickets are exclusive to club members. And if you are not a member, now is the perfect time to join. So head over to The Restishistory.com to sign up and grab your tickets.
不要错过。迫不及待地想见到大家。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
And of course, have access to a whole range of supplementary benefits. benefits. Once you have signed up to the restishistory.com, all you do then is log into the members area and you select festival and it's all very obvious. But you know what? There is a twist. If you do this, you will be entered into a genuinely unbelievable prize draw. And that prize draw, if you win, you and three other people, it's like the golden ticket in Charlie in the Chocolate Factory, because you will be given the chance to be upgraded to the premium experience and the premium experience will give you, among other things, unlimited food and drink for free all day.
当然，还可以获得一系列的补充福利。一旦您注册了restishistory.com，只需登录会员专区并选择“节日”选项，一切都非常直观。但您知道吗？这里还有一个惊喜。如果您这样做，您将有机会参加一场真正令人难以置信的抽奖活动。如果您赢得了这次抽奖，您和另外三个人将获得类似《查理和巧克力工厂》中“金奖券”的机会，因为您将有机会升级到高级体验，而高级体验将为您提供包括全天免费无限量餐饮在内的多项礼遇。
Do not miss it. Can't wait to see either. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
千万不要错过。迫不及待想见到大家。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。